ladies and gentlemen as you can tell by
the flicker of our lights intermission
is coming to an end
please remember to turn in your bounties
pick up your loot at the postmaster and
return to your seats in an orderly
fashion please be aware of the emergency
exits to your left and to your right and
enjoy the show
so what's up everybody we are back it is
september now which is crazy we're like
literally two-thirds through this year
and we are gonna basically jump in where
we left off we've got our guest
returning teddy welcome back sir
you are muted i think right now you
moved it down
it part two thank you for having me back
indeed part two we are back
we got the regular hostess with the
mostess over there the ninja who's gonna
host and run but he's got a busy
schedule so we're barely we're glad we
got him tonight the thursday works out
because this might not have happened
otherwise so yeah timing sometimes works
for the best
very happy very happy flight in the
morning but i was able to still make it
and uh the flooding did not stop my
flight thankfully i'm here with the
homies
i wanted you to excited give us give us
a break us off a little preview of the
remix as the is the case
what are you doing this weekend can you
tell people what you're doing yeah yeah
we're doing the last stand media live
show so it'll be good um
it's gonna be themed kind of with the
team then saturday will be the event and
uh will be your first time your boy will
be on stage and uh talking to the people
so the theme is gonna be greatest games
of all time and i'll give you a sneak
preview of the sense that
um everybody does not know ahead of time
what the other person is going to
present so we have 10 minutes
present and then um
we it's gonna be kind of travis will
appreciate this there will be a little
bit of a comedy central roasting vibe to
pick apart
yeah like this is travis
check this one out yeah
yeah they should have booked like this
is literally you know so
i got my choice you know i've never used
powerpoint before so that was an
experience learning doing stuff so that
was that but i feel pretty good about it
you know and then from there after that
10 minutes is up the audience will then
vote on who made the most compelling
argument for the greatest gameplay
i mean it's a life changer it's gotta be
somewhere on a lot of people's lists we
didn't get picked though let's be honest
yeah i mean look it's it there's so many
games you know um
bioshocks up there um
man it it became down to
impact
and also um
i try not to say because it's i already
it came out of impact and it came down
to another there was another one besides
that actually went way back
you know what i mean i went way back and
surprisingly surprisingly
nes right
i'm surprised not that far back but
actually
combat evolve was in the mix for a
little bit for me i remember that was in
the mix a little bit for me just for the
impact and what it did but i had to make
tough decisions i had to make tough
decisions i had to had to really
challenge myself on why so
it's not gonna be too much of a surprise
for people that know me but at the end
of the day it's going to be i'm gonna do
it in such a way that i hope
y'all gonna be like okay yeah he he
presented it well so let's see let's see
i'm excited
yeah it was well i told you combat
evolve was one bio
yeah what about you gentlemen like give
me top a few top games doesn't have to
be in any order specifically just like
quick lists that may pop in your head
just like top games for you guys all
time because i don't know
specifically
if everybody's heard him at some point
putting together a powerpoint about my
favorite video game and arguing why it
is sounds like
kind of sounds like something i would do
on my spare time i feel like i already
have a powerpoint for why hayward 2 is a
problem i made a powerpoint somewhere
yeah you guys probably have done that i
made a powerpoint screen vacation
excursions with like friends that we
were traveling with to like go through
them all i like researched them all made
a powerpoint we looked out on a friend's
tv they all laughed at me but it was
fine so
i was thinking about you bro like this
event
is perfect for it it screams to your
personality who you are you're a showman
you're a lat like i literally was like i
wish i was travis right now what would
travis do like like www tdd
yeah
you needed a little wwt bracelet
and then
remember this next time colin's hiring
you know i think my life stand with me
you're about to get in the bag let's go
that will continue
hey
mike's don't
get hooked up
savage
in one day so you can take one quick
comment
i think halo 2 is a perfect video game
and i could make a powerpoint
presentation of why it is for for many
many reasons but uh for me
the reason i've never given a 10 to any
game on ign in my reviews is because i
you know 10 is a masterpiece and it
means a game to me it means
and also i this is how i do my game of
the year selection as well
it has to be the game that has the most
impact on the community and makes like
the biggest footprint and i look for
games that like are changing the
industry which doesn't happen every year
it happened last year with half-life
alex which should have been game of the
year uh and amazing i think hades hades
is also amazing oh haters
i thought i feel like half-life alex
literally is going to be like
remembered in like the the spectrum of
games is in terms of what it did for vr
um but yeah um yeah halo 2 man that's
that's the one i would do a presentation
nice i also feel like there might not be
a lot of uh representation from the xbox
fam at that stand so i would i would
want to change
the thing that you would appreciate is
part of the rule set is when you had to
when you made your submission you had to
be like so because there was one neutral
person you're submitting to to make sure
that it's not hasn't been taken already
that's the other thing too so i was very
very fortunate did yours get taken on
their first try or was you know
i was lucky yeah myself nice
teddy i'm curious teddy what about you
so i always struggle with this question
because
there's so many different pieces of
criteria that you can judge a game on
but travis kind of hit the point that i
was going to make which is like for me
it usually is the game that makes the
most impact among either myself or or
and or the community but also
a game that
is almost timeless like not ever no
games ocarina of time i can already tell
by the prologue i'm i'm not going to
sacrifice time because our kind of time
i think has aged poorly
i i mean it's still it's definitely one
of those games that you could play today
and it's definitely it's playable like
it's sure it's clunky in some aspects
but it holds up
i was my pick is probably breath of the
wild
because that game
changed how open world games function
and since that point almost five years
ago everyone's been copying
uh that form impact
a little bit yeah they made a lot more
better than nintendo sadly
think about every ubisoft game before
breath of the wild
it was a collect-a-thon and a pointless
collect-a-thon unless you're an
achievement hunter breath of wild was
like well there's a thing over there and
there's a thing over there and they're
all meaningful in some way uh to
different players whereas previously
open world games were like we're just
going to sprinkle all this stuff around
so
and aside from all the other things that
game did that was just genius uh it's
not a perfect game in my opinion it's i
don't even i wouldn't even consider it a
masterpiece um but it's just one of
those games that
you i picked that game up and there's
always something to do
nice
respect respect e
uh mine has still just been mined
forever because
of oh i know yeah you do
no it's not it's long before that crono
chrono trigger for me
that one's
so depending on the people but you never
know but for me it's
like i can still hear like the mute
because the soundtrack's like on spotify
and i went to go play a song i'm like
yup two and it's been 20 years since i
played that game uh and i've never seen
like if
if square ever is going to do anything
after they finish final fantasy 7 remake
which is going to be a decade from now
if they could do that in the final
fantasy 7 remake style which i know they
will never do but the way they have like
the team up combat and everything that
they did in that i was like
it would be amazing but the way you had
like the duo and the trio attacks and
the different characters and traveling
through time and just between the story
the music the characters and just
the world like corona trigger for me
will still be one of my top games for
probably the rest of my life and i mean
god of war is like a game of my entire
franchise for ps4 but chrono trigger
it's like it got me into rpgs it got me
into just so many different things it
did to me personal impact i guess when
you guys say impact that one personally
was just like that stuck like that was
my snes game and will probably be
forever
that's a good pick
class never say that respect to all your
picks except for cogs who didn't tell us
what it was
thank you for having me in the show i
know it and you'll respect it when you
figure it out later oh you do know it
yeah
interesting
empty mass effect
can't be
so
as we took our little intermission
little uh
levity to get everybody back into the
show
this is basically part two of episode
164 as we are back from last week we
talked about basically everything for
the witch queen but not everything we'll
get to a couple pieces a bit later uh
but general runoff show that i kind of
want to go over with all of you guys
that we didn't get to last week because
we talked for three hours and i had like
man not making a five five-hour show
we dabbled in trials so we're gonna make
a dent not really a big damn show last
week well uh trials of osiris full
revamp coming so we're gonna go through
the details of that we've now had two
weeks of seasonal loss we actually get a
little better feel of what's going on
there um we can talk about uh anything
else with witch queen but i do want to
talk about the void 3.0 major piece we
didn't hit last week because that is
coming at the same time as witch queen
but kind of separate uh and then this
week if there's anything with regards to
iron banner matchmaking just anything
you guys have been hearing if we want to
get to that but the first piece is
trials of osiris and i kind of want to
cover couple cover a couple pieces with
regards to
the revamp before trials has in it or
before travis has an aneurysm
um
we'll start and we'll say if you're a
trials novice here's a quick breakdown
of what to expect on september 10 2021
we want to make trials more accessible
no matter your skill level or fire team
size we want to make trials more
rewarding whether you're winning matches
or earning reputation with saint 14
we want to make trials more engaging
testing out changes to elimination and
reintroducing labs to destiny 2. they
said their goals is basically to get
more people playing doing something
besides flawless or bust feeling they
like they can win more often feeling
like the rewards are on par with other
similar activities and embracing
movement conflict and resolution during
a match
so the main changes that they're going
to be doing is they're going to reduce
the requirements of the trials of trials
access quest to use lifetime valor which
actually is probably a bad thing to cut
off some of those people who are
you know getting in there pretty quick
and free
trials now allows queuing and
matchmaking without a full fire team we
want to allow more players to try the
mode out and start earning rewards even
if they didn't have a fire team you can
enter the playlist solo or with a friend
and matchmaking will fill the rest of
your fire team freelance trials which
will be available in labs uh going
flawless on your own will be hard to
impossible but i'm sure someone will do
it
uh they also said trials now requires
the annual expansion to play currently
it's beyond light up until witch queen
upon which queen's release
then you will have to own which queen it
just the expansion not the season passes
but just the expansion to play trials
um rule set changes i don't think i need
rewards and reputation we'll get to
later
i think that's the big stuff that i know
travis wants to talk about so let's
start there another big one for
matchmaking travis
you're on deck i know you're chomping at
the champion at the bit sorry take it
away you got it
i'm learning um
yeah so first i want to say i'm really
glad that trials is getting some
love i think no matter how you feel
about matchmaking and i'm probably on
the unpopular side of this opinion but
no matter how you feel about it i think
it's clear trials isn't working as it as
it exists right now and it needs work
really bad um and it has basically since
they relaunched it and they've tried
some stuff and it's not really worked
and i think the biggest issues have been
there's not really any incentive to play
it it's not rewarding unless you go
flawless uh it's
in the process of going flawless is
painful cheating is a plague uh i mean
it's not rewarding there's just lots of
lots of problems with it so i'm glad
that they're tackling it that's that's
the first thing i want to say before i
get into why i'm a little nervous about
some of these changes the second thing
is that i think every change they
announced except for matchmaking is a
really great idea and i include uh
gating trials behind the season pass in
that i think that needed to happen
because cutting cutting trials off and
putting it behind a
uh a free uh putting it on the other
side of the paywall means that it has to
be limited in what you can actually do
there and what the sandbox can include
and you know the rules and the maps that
they can if they have any any exclusive
maps which i think part of the reason
they haven't added maps is because
crucible and trials are all part of the
free-to-play sandbox
um etc
so i think that's a good thing i think
i'm glad that they're doing that um and
then all the other changes in terms of
taking away the token system and making
you earn rewards just by playing
fantastic uh all of the anti-cheat
efforts that they're doing amazing i i
hope that they work i'm sure there will
still be issues but i'm just glad that
there's like some serious action that
we're seeing
um
and yeah all basically the whole list
you read off aside from matchmaking i
think would have solved like 90 of the
issues
the problem i have with matchmaking is a
i don't think it's going to solve the
issue that they're trying to solve
and b
i think it's going to introduce more
problems than it actually fixes in in a
major way including making trials
sort of just like a comp 2.0 playlist
because
for people who don't want to go flawless
and they just want to take part in a
competitive playlist there's already a
playlist for those people it's called
comp playlist and it's actually pretty
good it's
it's water awards
what rewards i mean that's the thing but
i mean you could say that about what
rewards came from trials up until now
i mean there's unique weapons and armor
literally the message that's not in comp
there's a whole slew of armor and
weapons that's not a comp
yeah yeah
my point is that they're adding a whole
bunch of of like ways to get rewards
without going flawless now and they
could have just as easily done that to
the comp playlist
okay and that the the point is that the
comp playlist has a specific purpose
which is people want to be competitive
but possibly
don't uh
you know don't want to
have the whole experience of trials
which is a much sweatier experience it's
put on the headset have to communicate
have to find your own team uh have to
grind it out and get to that level where
you know after five wins that you're
you're really sweating a loss all that
stuff and they're basically saying okay
well people can still have that
experience but trials isn't only about
that now now you can just go in and sort
of like casually play and
not get that experience and to me it's
it it kind of is like okay so you want
the comp playlist to just combine with
the trials playlist except for it
segmented out in two separate types of
players it just doesn't seem very
logical to me
okay no i'm not going to say cog
i'll just i'll just not fight i just
want to get on into the logic i want to
get into the pack this is you're very
passionate about this and even though i
disagree i you know i respect you and i
want to i want to get where you're
getting that so for you um the the fact
that matchmaking is introduced
ruins your experience because you feel
that
the it's watered down because the other
teams are kind of willy-nilly or i guess
my question is
you know how do you contact me right
because you could still you know you
could still get your pre-determined team
which with the homies and and go slay so
i was just curious like is it a thing
that
you feel the overall like the same
entity of trials the sanctity of the
mode is it a sanctity thing
it's both it's one is is it's the idea
of trials of being that experience it
would be like if they said hey you know
we're going to make a version of each
raid that's match made and all of the
all of the stuff that you have to do
like the communication we're just going
to take that out of the game mode
because it doesn't really work for
matchmaking and then you know you don't
have to finish the raid but you can get
part way through and you'll get some of
the rewards okay so so you know
then people just wouldn't do it wouldn't
do that so my so that's one thing but
like the the sanctity of it is actually
not really my main concern my main
concern is that they're giving up on
what the idea of trials is and trials is
an idea that we know works because it
worked in d1 the entire time that it was
in d1 and i don't understand why they
think that it's tr that it's
the success of trials has changed
it's that they changed trials and it's
not it's not good like if they if they
just restored it to
what it what it's supposed to be then i
think it would be just as successful i i
think
they definitely need to improve the
player base and i think matchmaking is
going to do that 100 percent but you
know what what else would have improved
to prove the player base cross play
making the playlist more rewarding right
making new maps etc all the other
changes that they're already making
would have improved the player base and
so i think that doesn't that doesn't
change it also making the rewards uh
something that you can get not from uh
successive wins i think that's perfect
making it so that you can complete a
card after three losses and get that
seventh win is amazing all of those
changes that they're doing are really
good and i think would have helped the
player base uh matchmaking just sort of
changes the idea of what trials is and
it makes me feel like they're giving up
on trials like they're just like all
right well it didn't really work like we
tried to fix it and so now we're just
going to sort of make it a
a comp playlist 2.0 where you know you
can do this thing where you go uh
flawless and go to the lighthouse but
that's not the main thing that we want
you to go for anymore that's not really
like but a goal anymore i guess the
question is like
what has changed for the person who
still looks to aspire to be flawless
right what what has she like has the
reward like all right what i'm trying to
understand really because yeah where i
was similar to you
was when
d2 vanilla came out
with raids right when leviathan came out
and i remember they had the clan engram
thing
and i'll never forget this i was he
remembers like i was so disgusted that i
did the raid and i'm trying to get what
was the hand cannon that had the the the
rampage whatever you know what that's in
canada
midnight cool midnight cool oh yeah yeah
and sends it a pass those were like
iconic weapons from that rape and i'll
never forget
someone in my clan who did not raid
right went to hawthorne
and got
the joy so for me i was like how dare
you you did not even step foot in this
thing and you're eating now i know it's
different this is not apples to apples
but what i'm trying to say is you know
do you feel the flawless experience is
going to be watered down because you are
the guy you're the guy that goes in you
get the team you get your coordinated
thing like my feeling is wouldn't you be
happy that
the majority are not sweaty right and
that you still will have those matches
that's what when you're gonna stop
because there's against matchmade teams
sometimes right
we don't know that oh that's your
favorite okay that's part of my
thing is i think people are making
assumptions that like oh the playlist
will be big and it'll be filled with all
these different type of fire teams and
stuff like that and it's just like will
it like what if it's like the free they
they talked about freelance like this
could be a separate playlist a separate
matchmaking group so
it it it gives me a lot of questions and
i so there's there's two sort of buckets
of problems i have
one is with the matchmaking experience
which right now we don't know anything
about how it works but my assumption is
it's just going to match make every
round which that is like
that breaks the whole fantasy of trials
of going flawless with a group of people
because now you're
matching with different teammates every
every team so what i saw somebody
so i saw somebody in the comments
section said how is lfg different from
just matchmaking with people the
difference is lfg has a vetting process
you have to find people who are willing
to go through the lfg process which
gives a a little bit of a bearer of
entry rather than somebody who clicked
on a button and got into the match which
i think is a good thing because it means
that it's somebody who's serious about
playing seven matches or at least at
least seven matches and trying to go
flawless
uh it vets people for having a
microphone which i think is core you
wouldn't go into a raid you wouldn't go
into a raid with an lfg group that none
of them had mics so why would you deal
with trials because it's sort of
required
it doesn't it doesn't affect you if
you're going into match again i'm trying
to address both okay it's one the
matchmaking experience which if you're a
matchmaker i just think that at this
point you're not really getting a trials
experience you're just getting comp and
they're calling it trials it's just comp
2.0 tell me what is different about the
trials uh freelancers
let's talk about the elephant in the
room the elephant in the room is we
don't know how the matchmaking algorithm
is going to be right so to your point
right
i guess would it affect you any
differently if you are
pre-match made team that you know you
you did not match me you got your homies
and you're in a pool with
you know people who are not you know who
i also are in teams like if if that is
the case is that okay for you is that
because you're like okay these guys are
going by the sanctity of the of the game
and they i'm not fighting against you
know you know mix mitch max squad fire
team squad whatever a you know what i'm
saying like does that still give you
that adrenaline rush that yo i'm going
against that thing you know what i mean
so you're saying if it was three and it
was
i'm asking like what [ __ ] is saying so
if you were saying if if somebody's a
three they'll only match up with threes
then if they're a mixed match of ones or
twos those only play ones or twos
however they're put together
and then
solos are going to be tested in labs
later but that's a or a freelancer yeah
for freelance one but
i'm saying if if that happens like yeah
so the answer to your question of how it
affects me is that i don't know but i'm
pretty sure it affects me in a bad way
because uh why why would you play in the
ultra sweaty 3v3 matchmade groups if you
could go flawless with a group of two
that's usually like on a carry team like
does this affect the 3v3 playlist
because why would you go through a super
sweaty experience if you're good enough
you and you know me and teddy can get
into a group with the random and get
with these match made playlists and win
seven matches so does it does it
negatively and like what is the point of
that like why do i need matchmaking in
trials if i have the comp playlist and i
could have just put weapons in there or
maybe even the trials weapons i just
don't understand the use for this it
sort of is is just taking it the other
thing is but i mean you check
sorry
if they do the other if they do the
other thing and say okay we're going to
matchmaker we're going to keep you
together until you complete a card okay
then you've got the problem of you know
what if somebody leaves part way through
there's no there's no vetting for like
they're dedicated to playing through all
the matches they just clicked on a
button and they could leave after three
matches and then you're like oh crap and
if you're if you're switching around
between teams then you don't get that
whole climbing the mountain experience
where like i'm with my squad and we're
getting it just it it feels so distant
from what trials is i don't know why
they're giving it the same name it might
as well be a different game wow this is
this is
what does it have in common with the
trials experience if it's a match made
mode where you don't you don't get on
mic and you don't talk to your people
and you don't even stay with the same
team for something you
can still do that that's not being taken
away from you you're acting as if it's
being removed from you that you can only
play
with you know the match made squad you
can still go with your tactical squad
with the communications and hot bikes
and good
why would i if i can get to why would i
why would i if i could go to the the
lighthouse with uh with just teddy and
me and it's a lot easier experience so
why so why would you be upset that
you're smashing people and still going
to the lighthouse because now trials is
dead
how is it dead when it's more peaceful
because it's not trials anymore now it's
just teddy and i going through a a comp
playlist where at the end we get to go
to you know what i mean like the whole
it's it's just like if if they told you
okay you can either do a raid or we'll
break down the raid into each encounter
and you can match make each encounter
and it's way faster and way easier and
it's less sweaty you don't have to
organize a crew and then all of a sudden
that whole experience of going into a
raid with six people and doing the whole
thing is dead because no why would you
ever do that when there's this
alternative that's really easy but then
what you're saying
and then you go damn it but my i want to
do a six person raid but that that just
isn't a thing that really people do
anymore or why would you do it okay like
take for example something like and i
haven't played apex in ages but that's a
three-person team right
i'm asking like i'm gonna play kind of
dumb here because i haven't played apex
but only a few times and it's been a
while can you do matchmaking in apex
yes
okay but apex isn't the same experience
you don't have to win seven apex matches
together but is it
it's not what is it the intensity of any
apex match just as important as
567 when you're up at the top it's like
i know it's one like you know a set of
rounds but it's still you could get
matched up with a set of people
and it's gonna still have a lot of
weight on how your match goes which
could be
you know if they win that apex match as
a match made three team versus you know
it could be twos could be ones could be
threes
that's one of those things like i don't
know it's like apex that's that's really
not apples to apples because it's two
separate playlists one for comp and one
for casual and if you go into comp with
a match made team then you know unless
you're low ranked if you're super high
ranked and you do that you're taking a
big risk because you're going to go
against people who are stacked and
you're probably going to lower your
ranking and that sort of thing charles
doesn't have a system like that well
it's like
it's like a car it's a card-based
experience and they're sort of saying
okay so we're going to remove the card
based experience because the point is
not to go flawless anymore we're going
to remove the having a consistent
firearm
for you
with that fog come on now you go extra
to find the point is not to go flawless
anymore
that's what he read that's what ivantas
read right you can still go flawlessly
they don't want everyone going flawless
or but right and racing that card
you're taking that literal like they're
just removing it like like flawless is
going from the game but it's it's not
the point of the match made playlist
they said it's like next to impossible
but a few people will do it right for
the people yeah for the people who
choose to do matchmaking correct yeah if
the point is not to complete the card
and go flawless if the point is not to
stay with you i think you're overstated
the point is not they did not say you're
putting words in their mouth they did
not say
i'm not putting words into their mouth
i'm interpreting what they have created
that doesn't mean that we are removing
flawless from the game
everything is of match
the whole concept of flawless or bust is
that you're with your crew and you're
going to go flawless or bust and now
that's not a thing you're not with the
crew you're with random people every
match is my assumption
i was like the biggest thing that this
does
it was like you your experience likely
will not change
or maybe the lower cards could get
easier but if matchmade
matchmade teams
get a chance to play the mode
this in bungie's eyes is a way to let
people dabble in a mode they otherwise
see as an impossible wall to entry the
average person looks at trials and says
i can't play it at all period there's no
way for me to try this thing i don't
know the same thing about raids they say
the same thing about raids yeah and see
how many people don't play those group
looks at a raid and goes five friends
together to figure out these puzzles
that's insurmountable i wish there was
matchmaking
but the community behind raids is really
like adamant they're like that's part of
the experiences
of people that ask for matchmaking and
raids
they are but but they haven't added it
because bungie has itself defended the
mode and said we like the idea that you
have to get on a mic and nobody wants to
do a raid with like three randoms that
don't have a mic like that's awful it's
just a terrible experience right
i was like and that's fair but we gotta
get we got to get teddy here because we
did not let you know it's something else
it's not trials anymore
where are you at this on teddy
raids require communication
some like pvp matches i would say that
that guy has not played trials then i
actually know who he is and i guarantee
he has
i've just seen him
he should know it requires communication
you're literally going to go into a you
can like you can follow people as a
group stick together and then shoot the
other people in the head it's not like
hey i've got this ball that i have to
dunk over here at this exact time
mechanics right you the mechanics are
different than like communication will
communication take you to another level
absolutely and that's the difference is
it's i i disagree i disagree with your
premise that it is i think i think
you're oversimplifying the level of
complexity that is involved in trials at
a high level i really i've i'm not
saying that no i've won
your experience with raids is much
higher than your experience with trials
and so you're over simplifying it a
little bit and it does require
communication no i fully get that that's
what i'm saying is what i like i sat
there and played with two people that
are like 10 stages beyond anything i
ever will be probably in this game like
and i listen to them communicate it is
like
it's insane what they can do with just
words to be like you're like i know what
everything is going on right now that is
a different level
and that is the same thing as people who
in raids are like hey do this now switch
this over here cool
but in a different scheme can people go
into a pvp setting as a trio and have
some success in this mode that
previously was inaccessible today they
can and it's and it's called comp but
those are not the same comp is not the
same rule set it's like it's a different
rule
it's a comp 2.0 playlist
yeah
i got teddy we've been we've talked i
got i got a lot to tackle here there you
go so
when trials okay let's back up a little
bit when trials released in 2015
the gaming landscape was very different
there was nothing quite like trials and
i still think it's one of the most
unique game modes
any company's ever made
and when they were telling us they were
going to bring it into d2 they said when
they were baking it we don't want to
bring we don't want to put the exact
same thing over and that's exactly what
ended up happening for better or worse
they just ported essentially the same
thing but i think
that the
2020 version of trials does not work in
the modern gaming landscape for a couple
reasons
one the
gamer's attitude towards accessibility
and
availability of attempting something in
a game has completely shifted and bungie
has made that very clear across the
entire game that they want people to be
able to approach activities and trials
and raids are these two things that are
very difficult to approach
excuse me
the
to your point about communication
i can jump into
almost any pve activity with the regular
people that i play with and
we unless it's like a grand master
we can generally not communicate at all
and still have success because we've
played with each other enough times that
we know generally speaking what the
other person is going to do or what
they're thinking i can usually predict
what my raid squad is going to do in
most situations without me having to say
anything or them having to say anything
i think pvp is different though
the variability of pvp and the
experiences that you have in pvp are
vastly
more complex than a pve encounter that
is generally speaking a static
uh situation that isn't the variability
is a lot lower like i know that this
enemy will do x thing but of course
happens but but in pvp that's not the
case like if that's the case
and when you brought up apex i was going
to say that apex is infinitely more
variable than trials osiris or destiny
pvp because
no no two games are the same in that
game like with trials once you
understand the map and once you've
played enough rounds you kind of end up
doing the same stuff over and over but
it's just changing because of what your
opponents are doing because it's a very
reactionary game correct um
sorry i'm trying to like backpaddle i
don't know
i don't know because there's a lot so
all the changes that they said i'm i'm
for with the exception of
the skill with matchmaking which i guess
we kind of have to see how that works
and i'm i'm like 50 50 on the solo
queueing thing and let me explain why
break it down
so
they're introducing a freelance players
in the labs playlist and not in the
trial and they're implementing solo in
the trials playlist but i'm assuming
this is a temporary change because
they're probably going to do something
like iron banner i'm bannered yeah or
you can only solo queue
um or are they i'm sorry they want to
make it so you can only solo queue in
the freelance playlist but they're
in order to get a larger player pool to
test this they're going to let it go in
the normal game mode and maybe maybe
maybe they will enable it just if it
works right
um
the problem with
trials now versus the destiny 1 version
is in destiny 1 you could just play the
card and even if it was sweaty because
spm and destiny 1 was even worse than
what we have now you were still rewarded
you were still rewarded like you
the the bounties gave you you know the
drop and your time was rewarded for what
you did but the current version of
trials does not
uh have that it's very much a you either
go flawless or you bust right another
thing that they've really really really
hammered with destiny 2 compared to one
is uh the rich get richer in destiny 1
if you were a good player
and you had the best gear you were
always going to beat uh worst players
and battlefield is another genre that
has suffered this problem for many
iterations of the games they've
addressed this in more recent versions
of battlefield where uh leveling up
doesn't necessarily get you better
equipment or perks or guns that make you
uh you know more powerful because then
it de-incentivizes a new player picks up
the game or when the game is
free on games for goal or epic game
store or something it makes it harder to
experience that and so i think they're
definitely addressing that with this
concept
of solo king because they want this mode
to be approachable but they're not just
giving away the loot
um
you if you want the adept weapons you
still have to go flawless uh correct i
think they've i think they really hit
the mark with the depth weapons not just
in the pvp not just about the fatal
rewards
it's
they're not super overpowered but if
you're a top-tier pve or pvp player they
do make that enough of a difference that
you feel like okay i got this really
good smg in trials and i got a good roll
on it and it's adept this is totally
worth it
um versus the the normal version but
it's not like this it's not like d1
where
uh
you know i got i got this weapon
that is just so much better than
everyone else's and right the poor the
average player cannot
obtain this shout out to the summoner
right right they're not they're not
handing out this stuff yeah i think the
travis's point the
the solo experience
doesn't ruin my experience because if
you if you you know if if you go into a
comp if you go on a comp game right now
with a three stack you can still match
solo people yeah um i don't know why
they i think people just don't know the
freelance playlist exists sometimes uh
because it is like a small note or it's
probably one and twos but yeah
generally speaking when you go up
against a two stack and then a solo
player in a in comp when you're when
you're threatening i did a lot of comp
this weekend i mean
you're gonna mop the floor with them
because they can't communicate like
you're
not always like there's definitely some
people that are cracked and you're just
gonna lose but generally speaking you're
gonna win because you you have an
advantage because you can talk and you
can say that guy just picked up heavy
he's got this weapon or that guy just
killed me here he's standing here versus
the players can now they're kind of
addressing this which is kind of cool
because they just enabled chat on cross
play yep uh in game and destiny's like
yeah literally today chat
yeah it was today um destiny's chat uh
in-game chat feature i've personally i
know no one that's actually used it but
like it's there right so come on travis
in game chat come on
i think they're i think they're taking
the barriers
i love it
i have i have a comeback here
i think
i think they're just they're lowering
the barrier to entry that's the goal
with this decision
like
their goal is to lower the barrett entry
so that the average player can try
trials because the playlist is so low
um and
it might be a problem when we play but
i'm not the right person to ask because
i play trials very casually uh okay i go
flawless occasionally and usually only
if it's like if there's a flaws or
whatever let me ask you a question like
with with these proposed changes for you
personally right you know do you feel
when you you know you got your three
stack or whatever and let's just say you
know
you do find out that if there's some way
that you can find out that who you are
playing against is literally match made
like i guess what i'm struggling to
understand with travis like why is that
an issue like shouldn't it be like yo we
getting the you know
one of these steps towards the
mountaintop right got me one of these
things as a because to me the hardcore
that i deal with
they get frustrated because they say yo
all i'm playing is sweaty sweaty sweaty
sweaty sweaties all day and then they
like yo like it it it ruins my
experience and i understand this point
where
all the other things will increase the
pop the uh the pull he's right travis is
right about that all the other things
still will increase the pool and i think
matchmaking will get credit for the
stuff that the other
fixes and that's valid and that's bad
that is the part i'm with you i am with
that but again some people have no way
to even some people still will see that
and say hey you need a team of three
and they don't even have a way to go
like just dabble like hey maybe i'll try
this thing and that's why
go ahead right lfg no no and i'm not and
we got it we got to be real too this way
i'm
we got to be real too that
let's be real travis you're a beast
right
if me i come in there with my one point
kd right
and they the first thing dudes is like
yo trials report i had a dude i think
y'all was in a party chat and i was
clowning somebody in my car saying let
me see your trousers oh you'd even been
to the lighthouse so what you talking
about and i'm like damn like they pulled
up my whole resume and it was like they
already would deal with the kid so it
you understand like it's that you guys
are so good and for the average guy
he's getting shown the door he's not
getting into the club he is not the lfg
for certain dudes
it's almost the equivalent of the
gallahorn days for certain dudes if they
resume a right that's all i'm trying to
say so my last point to say back to
teddy and travis just that you know i
would think that you know if out of the
seven win card you've got two to three
of those were match made
part of me was like yo we went flawless
you know what i'm saying and we really
had to kill ourself every single match
wouldn't it be a fun experience
or you still like nah i want every match
to be the best of the best for the
spirit of competition that's my question
it would it would be it would be fun if
trials was in a good place right now
so you guys have repeatedly said why
does solo queueing affect you it doesn't
change your experience and i just
fundamentally disagree with that and
here's why
if trials is broken right now if it
doesn't work there's two ways to fix it
one way is to look at the competitive
experience you're curating and try to
make it better the other way is to give
up and not make it the same experience
it was and so it's not that
that one solo queuing affects me because
it changes the mode it's that it means
that
they're not they don't have a plan to
fix the experience for a three-player
stack but they're giving up on that that
they're saying hey that experience that
we originally were building that was a
three-player competitive mode is now
not our priority we we've tried to fix
it we couldn't and so now our our
solution is going to be to pivot and to
create this alternate experience that
isn't well that thing that it was and so
to me it's saying
the trials that we tried to do we give
up and now we're going to just try this
other thing so it does affect me because
it means that they're not going to fix
the core experience and so maybe i'll
get a few easier maps so how do they fix
it in your eyes if they yeah that's
what's going to say how do they fix it
i have i have thoughts i mean i've said
on a million episodes of this show and
fire team chat all the things i think
they need to do to fix trials and i'm
sorry i missed a couple little i'm sorry
i'm sorry yeah but no it's totally fine
but uh i i think teddy uh knows where
i'm as i talk to him about this all the
time i i kind of disagree with that
because they've get them teddy were
these changes so one of the things that
they're doing is they're reducing the
timer uh to a minute 30 which is what
they didn't want as well yeah they they
didn't d1 as well right and and then
they also said that on certain weekends
in the labs playlist not just the solo
labs plays but the labs
match made three player playlists uh
they're gonna have objectives and
different things like that and so i
think they are trying to refine the
experience because i think straight
elimination the original vision of
trials doesn't work anymore the destiny
player base has gotten way smarter since
destiny came out like players understand
things players are watching youtube
videos players are watching these top
level streamers and so destiny has
evolved into this game where
it's very reactionary you're very
passive and that's where trials needs to
change because trials is
trying to lower some barriers to entry
sorry
right yeah the the lab's uh introduction
of objectives and different things like
that is their attempt to to solve this i
i think it's a i think it's a
multi-staged
fix i don't think it's like here's one
patch that's that's done and done and
like they're gathering data that's what
labs was designed to do was i hope
you're right i i hope you're right that
they are
but i i just don't know if you can get
the
i don't know if you can get it back in
the bottle you know what i mean
you know what i mean
think of this like it's all the ways
that this new model affects the old way
right so let's say i'm playing trials by
myself my homies are are busy they have
loved ones unlike me right and so
they've got stuff to do this weekend i
love it right we love you
they've got loved ones who aren't teddy
who never who almost never plays with me
and
we played together last night until like
2 30 yeah
let's say you're doing that if i try to
find lfg i don't know if you've ever
tried to find an lfg on destiny for
trials but it's already pretty hard now
it's going to be impossible because all
those people that would normally do lfg
are going to be matchmaking no i want
that experience
making you think they're going to do it
because we know if you jump in
matchmaker you ain't going to the
lighthouse like that with all the
randomness that you gotta do and every
come on try at least can we at least
admit that the playlist is going to be
affected the amount of leds is going to
be affected by these yes yes the volume
i would agree
i don't mean dead i just mean fewer but
you also don't know potentially if the
barrier to entry is lowered and people
try this then they might actually be
willing to actually go look into it
deeper if somebody's like hey i tried
trials you know the matchmaking was like
hit or miss
is there more i can do and if somebody
goes then to go look deeper into trials
then they may find that type of thing as
well that that that is one possible
outcome but i think we can agree so is
mine mine's also a possible outcome and
and if there's fewer people on lfg which
i think we can all agree at least in
some cases there probably will be
then that means that the barrier of
entry is actually higher for matchmade
teams because now the pool is smaller
and there's going to be there's going to
be more competition to get onto those
teams oh your kd's not above a one point
eight dollars not above a 2.3 well then
you're not gonna get on my team because
now now it's more competitive in the
lfgs that do exist i just it's it's
listen guys i'm sort of being devil's
advocate with this because
i believe in this mode i think that it
can exist and i think they've already
they've already told us they're going to
implement most of the fixes that would
have fixed it and i don't think
matchmaking is going to be the silver
bullet everyone thinks it is i think
it's going to introduce more problems
than than it's it's actually fixed for
the lfg community you could serve for
the lfg community of trials that they
are oh what was them that they will not
be able to find could
another three point okay for lots of i'm
concerned for lots of different parts of
the community but i can see the culture
of not the biggest it seems not the
biggest part who ain't playing the damn
game that's the one why why would you
why would you go out of your way to
assemble a dream team
if you could go to the lighthouse any
other way but you you're assuming you're
talking about the house you're talking
about the five percent of players right
now
who
like much less play trials and then the
smaller piece of that who consistently
go to the lighthouse bungie is trying to
open this up to like another 40
possibility who might dabble in crucible
who might see another thing on the
director that they can actually go try
without going outside of the game and i
think like the biggest thing that bungie
is trying to do is make more of their
game accessible does this possibly alter
your experience maybe maybe but also on
the other side it also my point my point
is maybe like i have concerns i'm not
saying matchmaking has killed trials
it's over you sound you sound scary you
sound much more than like hey this might
be a thing you sound like your child is
this is like yo they are messing with
the purity of this mold and you said
they might as well slap cough on this
joint they bought it
bro you win this don't give me
it's basically the same thing it's comp
it's just comp 2.0
at that point what's the point of this
of having a separate playlist but here's
my point here's my point and i'll let
teddy pick it up because i think teddy
was going to say some stuff that i agree
with about solo queueing all that and he
didn't get to get to it i want to give
it back to him but
uh
my my thing is that
i've already forgotten my thing
sorry i was going to say it there you go
about the opinion about the opinions i
have yes yes i say them passionately
because i'm passionate about the mode
and also i get i make a living having
opinions about things i would be if i
don't do i don't have opinions
half-heartedly i like i like state
concerns and
and the voice of i like to i like to be
the guy who's like um i don't know maybe
we should we should all look out for
this so that's awesome devil's having an
action oh
have you guys thought about it you know
so the point
i'm going to turn your analogy kind of
upside down so you're comparing it to
comp
how many how many people are hitting
legend in freelance comp
it's not a high number talk about
give them
okay before it was to get the weapon
that they were introducing every season
the pinnacle but then they got rid of
that so now what do you do you either do
it for the the powerfuls which kind of
don't matter anymore or you're doing it
to legend because not everyone has
unbroken right people you're talking
like a guy who doesn't enjoy playing
comp because you know what the actual
purpose of comp
it's not to go legend it is to rank up
to a level that you fit in on the skill
based spectrum and then play with people
who are your peers that's the point
but that doesn't
if you're a mythic level mythic one then
you're playing with other mythic ones
and your goal isn't necessarily to go to
legends it's to play with the peers who
are at your relative skill level and try
to get better by playing with them
that's that doesn't work not to hit
legends
dude this is my point like i'm saying
why doesn't that exist in destiny it
should but anyway oh it's because well
okay it's because of the weight because
the game is not ever going to be quite
that mlg so you're never going to be
this esports thing that you want bro
why can't it be because it's the most
unbalanced broken weapon variable perk
game out it's like because
you sound like me
bro i've given up on that pipe dream of
the esport it's just and so how's bungie
but you acting surprised you're acting
like you didn't know that you knew this
already everybody hearing this everybody
hearing this he's agreeing with me no
you but you knew this already this is
not new information right this is
something that we've screened from the
mountaintops that pvp and pve should
have been separated a long time ago this
is something we've all said so at this
point new rad i think said it the chat
like to me it's like this is really the
arcade shooter with some competitive
elements
it's some in some regards it's not this
this this purity this bliss of of of
one-on-one arena shooter like a halo
that there's there's levels to this
right because there's balance there's
map placement there's so much things all
over the place but it just introduced
like gold
this season
i agree with you on everything you just
said trials is unbalanced it's probably
never going to be balanced that's
general it's it's comp and pvp are
probably never going to be competitive
and i think the most crucial point that
we agree on is that bungie has given up
on trying to make it that yeah so i
agree so i agree with i agree with you
but do i have a right to be sad about
the one yeah no destiny no i agree now
officially i agree i guess why i'm so
passionate and i'll finish my thing i'm
sorry today because this is a good
meeting man travis is hugging it out
right now so like the thing is
where you
are with that is how i feel
with rage right so if this same thing
happened to raids then i would
definitely understand the patch because
i'm like damn the sanctity of doing vog
and doing king's fall and that
pre-determined thing you know that that
meant something i met people because of
that and that was my brother and whoever
in your case you you met people you went
to the lighthouse and that communication
that that the the reactionary of all
those variables of competition right
that means something to you i know where
you're at you know what i'm saying so
maybe then i'll be like okay you know i
feel away but i'm at this point now
they're never going to do it and at the
point i don't want the mode to die i
just don't i i'd rather sacrifice
a little bit of my purity
for this thing to exist and more people
can get a part of it but teddy i am
sorry it is all you have
100 agree with you i wish they would
have gone the other way and tried it but
i agree that the mode had to evolve it
is not working as it currently is and i
said that at the top of this segment and
i 100 agree i just have two more tumor
kind of final
points so the first is to kind of
address like why it's never going to be
like that just gonna let you guys have
you can't have a game that's
approachable and accessible and
competitive
like that that doesn't in my
in modern gaming at least like like i
would say from i don't think so because
easy easy to pick up hard to master
there's lots of games like that
yeah but they're not destiny
yeah like i agree the sandbox of destiny
is brutal i think what you mean to say
is that you can't have a game that has
everything in it and is balanced right
like like look at something like that
like like overwatch
that game is easy to pick up but hard to
master or even apex too like or fortnite
for that matter like there's nuance to
those games but but they don't have the
pve element that destiny has which just
it throws a wrench so and so for that
reason and because of their their core
pillar design of they're never going to
separate the two sandboxes everything
has to function exactly the same as it
does in one or the other i think it'll
just never be that experience uh my
second thing that i wanted to say so
this is an anecdotal thing so there's
two people that play with regularly on
on xbox and now with cross play we can
play anywhere and they're
i would say they're pretty casual
players but they get on every night and
they do everything right like they look
at the director and they go okay this is
the thing i know how to do and they just
they just knock that stuff out right
and
sometimes i'll play trials with them but
the experience playing with me
not that i'm like a good player but just
because my spm is so insane they can't
keep up yeah but when they play with a
third friend who doesn't get on as often
they can they actually have a good time
and they reasonably get to three wins
which is always their goal they just
want to get the three minutes they're
not even trying to go flawless they're
like oh we make it to five that's just a
plus right
um
and so they have more fun without you
sounds familiar well yeah that's that's
what i'm getting at so that's a whole
different verse
with the solo queue with the solo queue
system they can duo queue together and
still have that same experience they're
not trying to go fast if they go
flawless that's even better now and now
with the new system
they don't have to just bust after three
losses they could play 30 games and out
of those 30 if they win the seven they
get the seven tier reward and and if
they lose they've done that without
matchmaking though
no they couldn't because there's only
two of them
there's only there's only two i thought
you said they had a third friend they
have a third but but he only gets on
like every couple weeks the two of them
play every night together
so
i think for players like them who are in
the middle of the bell curve it's
perfect like that that's that's that's
what they're designing this for
yeah it's not for us the change is not
oh this is the last point sorry there's
a third point we're the third final
point
we do
the the four the four of us are very
privileged to have people that we play
with regularly and communities that that
you know i can literally pick up my
phone and be like
dude come play with me right now or you
know discord message someone would be
like
that is so not normal it is so easy for
me to assemble a raid squad it's a joke
or even a pvp squad like
like the other last night when we played
iron banner we already had a six stack
and i was like i was complaining about
this a six stack we didn't lose the game
travis like we just mercy every game
and we either did i think most people do
that
uh
most people don't have that much trials
all right so why are you pushing it
because it's not fun
stop bitching i i i think the average
player just doesn't have that you know i
i try to view things
from a normal player right like
not me who's doing every every single
thing in the game and i have you know
this this network of people that i'm
like hey let's go do the thing that i
need to do or hey let's do this stupid
thing that noah like i'm not gonna lfg
some random triumph or some [ __ ] like
that like that's just not gonna happen
like it's like squad let's go do this
like the homies we gotta we gotta get
this done done
uh or trials for that matter like it
applies everywhere in the game so like
uh that's that's the final point i want
to make we're we're privileged that we
can we can call upon the community and
and and get stuff done
yeah no absolutely absolutely okay
because i don't want this to go on yeah
it'll go i know we'll go on forever i uh
i i totally want to understand where you
guys are going from i just wanted to
voice
uh
my concerns and i think um
i mean i'm interested either way to see
where this is going and regardless i'm
glad they're changing something because
what they're doing right now isn't
working i'm willing to make a
gentleman's bet that the changes that
they're going to introduce in
uh
are the changes coming this season or
next season next season next season
september 21st right literally next week
yeah okay
i'm willing to bet that the changes that
they're introducing they're going to
take those changes and are the things
that they're doing and this data that
they're gathering is to validate the
changes they're making for which queen
and i think it's going to work in which
queen
really to some extent i don't think it's
gonna be perfect but it's gonna be
definitely better than what we're gonna
get this season
because that's that's generally their
cadence they introduce something
experimental like this
it's either it's either to assess
something or they're validating changes
that are already in the pipeline that
they want to see if it's going to work
or not right there's usually that half
not being a half step before that full
set yeah your bet with me is you think
i'm going to bet against next season
being better than this season
[Laughter]
yes you think i'm going to take that bet
against again or they won't change
anything next season
or that they won't change anything
they'll just they're just going to leave
it the way it is right now
or when we get the changes in a week and
a half do you take that with that i
would be careful because some of that
stuff's involved so that i agree i agree
with almost everything that they're
doing except for matchmaking i think
that other stuff is going to make trials
a lot better and then and then uh
matchmaking will get credit for it it'll
be like oh look how accessible it made
it and be like well i mean now you could
play on a card with three losses like
that alone makes it way more accessible
because it means it's not as high risk
you don't get booted out every time you
lose like that like for the potassius of
the world that's all you needed to do to
make paul want to grind his seven wins
like the the match
had to catch up i'm sorry
i talked to him on fire
i'm excited for this because i listened
to the whole episode
but i was like i mean even for even for
somebody like me like
i have really crappy days and i have
okay days at pvp but i was like there's
a point of him like hey i'm sitting at
home it's late there's nobody i know
that's online right now i can jump in
and at least like i could goof around in
a solo match made playlist or even just
match made and i might win a few rounds
in between things and other stuff like
that and it's a way for me to get access
to the game mode i'm not gonna get the
best rewards i'm not gonna go flawless
i'm probably not gonna get most of the
entire weekend but if i can get a few
rounds in maybe get that three win just
because i'm so low
most of that playlist is still like
unattainable at that level but it's
still something that i can get into and
i think that's what bungie is going for
for most people anyway if i were bungie
i would if i were bungee i would have
released all of the patches that they're
doing except for matchmaking first and
then seeing if matchmaking was still
necessary because
being able to play on a card that's lost
is already huge for accessibility and
for getting any rewards for people don't
go flawless cross play improves the
player base significantly they're
already doing a lot of stuff that fixes
a lot of the problems of trials making
it more rewarding making it less like
sweaty and competitive i wonder if they
need
uh the freelance playlist and
matchmaking too
to to fix it or if it's not really
necessary but i guess we'll never know
because my final point same time all
this is great
is travis are very disappointed in you
because you know what you missed out on
you literally missed out on more help
ibanta segments because of this
you're not looking at the big picture
sir i i messed up how am i how am i
gonna do helpy bonta sections when now
he can just match me you know what i
mean
it's
impossible see now you can do your
pre-made healthy vodkas
match teams
that's tough how after all the end of
this i get crapped on i don't know
activities however there's gonna be
activity rules that changes round time
is being reduced in 90 seconds from 120.
uh emotes stay in first person swords uh
cannot be equipped unless you have ammo
special and heavy ammo no longer carry
over between rounds i didn't even know
the heavy carried over but special
definitely changed uh to teddy's point
of the rich get richer that's like a 100
yeah that's rich rich get richer facts
uh that was a big problem in d1 that was
a big problem once you get steamroll and
they got the the special forget it it
also made it hard to keep track like
like you know what on round one if
someone has a sniper on and they sh and
i hear two shots being fired and no
one's dead
i know they're done there's no sniper
shots
like that's it so we can you know we
have the shotgun too but after that it's
like well
we died two of us died did you pick up
the special oh like
[Laughter]
so it's a good change
apparently um i just figured out because
there's people like hey maybe you'll
play trials i'm like yeah my video
series is going to be uh tragic trials
just how terrible that's going to go the
tragedy of dorothy bontes
wise i love it that's if i play with
travis that's when he's going to scold
me
oh i'm not mean guys i'm fun in trials
teddy's played with me yeah this
previous hours proved that exact point
yes
rewards and reputation saint is now
getting new trials ranks reputation and
a rewards track trials tokens have been
retired reputation is gained at match
complete based on the number of rounds
won on your ticket tickets track up to
20 round wins now emphasizing winning
individual rounds for the core rewards
gives every player more achievable goals
at all skill levels since you don't have
to win full matches to get rewards you
always have a reason to keep trying even
if you are behind ranking up gives you
trials in grams more on that in a bit
powerful trials engrams show up every
three ranks before your first reset of
the season
uh just like other rip uh other ritual
reputations there's other rewards just
like previously you got
you know upgrade modules and things like
that looks like you got a couple weapons
in ranks as well that are actually going
to be tossed in the middle
passages
passages no longer track losses a
passage is either flawless or not this
allows you to keep playing and earning
match and round wins for rewards players
may continue to reset their passage
after a loss but are no longer forced to
after three losses passages track up to
20 rounds one we can see that uh
passages have been reordered mercy is
not super use super useful unless you're
trying to go for flawless and have had
all their prices significantly reduced i
still don't know why so many things cost
random amounts in this game
artifact that was different artifact
grind
stop the artifact pricing anyways
passages are now account wide as well
um let's see each week there are two
pinnacle challenges four trials win
seven matches total on a given weekend
and win 50 rounds
that's not a small number
bonus progress based on the number of
wins on your card three five seven win
challenges have been removed uh once you
max out the reputation you can reset and
claim the ascendant chart or exotic
engram like other rituals additionally
we'd like to keep players going deeper
into the cards rather than resetting
each time they lose a match match wins
on a seven win card of the same
chance to drop extra trials in grams
master working materials and high stat
armor
the lighthouse experience isn't changing
a unique pinnacle adept each week
the first time you visit on your account
all of the mods and cosmetics are
available in the chest to reward return
visits
trials engram the trials and gram now
decrypts
a random selection from current armor
and non-adept weapons you do not need to
unlock a piece of armor or weapon before
it shows up in the engram you can focus
your engrams this is something you were
probably waiting on
uh at saint 14 decrypt specific items
that you have already received if you
have gone flawless that week you can
focus additional drops for the weekly
adept weapon
but expect it to be expensive
uh matchmaking you can now start
matchmaking with players that have the
same number of wins on the card
and with similar trials game performance
of the given week we have a bunch of
different factors planned and we'll be
watching and tuning these to balance
match quality versus matchmaking time
if matchmaking takes too long it widens
the similarity check
and security we've covered anti-cheat
uh when trading account recoveries and
of course the paywall
anything in there that we have thoughts
on
uh it's all positive
i like almost all those changes yeah
yeah yeah really cool so far i haven't
really encountered any cheaters as far
as i can tell so okay
yeah i mean
really positive i i i just like you know
the the diversity of the things they've
added and um i mean i felt really well
thought i'll be honest you know this is
a this is something that's very complex
i love trials and you know i didn't know
what they were going to do and to be
honest i didn't think they were going to
go this deep to be honest i thought it
was just going to be
you know even at some point not even get
the damn anti-cheat but you know i do i
do like that i do i i'm not gonna lie
like
the focusing really
you know speaks to me because there are
times
it's so hard enough to get to the
lighthouse so to just get just certain
thresholds to three to five to seven or
whatever it is right yeah and it's just
like nothing sucks when you finally do
it and you get that crap weapon with the
garbage roll and you like damn i got
this wack messenger with no desperado
and e went one time and he got it
i'll be able to focus if it actually
happens
they said you can after you've gone
followers yeah if you go flawless it's
going to be expensive but you will be
able to it says yeah
that's so awesome yeah man so yeah that
part i love that like one thing since
the the the benefit of the seasonal
model that has now benefited trials i
feel is the umbral focusing because that
always helps try to dig down the key is
going to be how much materials and stuff
like that and the last point i'll say is
i'm a huge fan i've always eno's i've
always been upset that trials
disproportionately does not reward with
prisms and cores the way the other molds
do they treat it like this stepchild and
i'm like this is way more harder to do
with way more variables and you're not
even giving me mats like that's bad so
this is cool i like it that's all i'm
going to say
agreed i still think you should i still
think they need to work on
actually i won't say anything negative
i've already talked about this enough
but i have a lot of people
come on i was i was going to talk about
the end the end rewards and stuff like
that but i i think um
i've already hammered on that enough but
yeah i i like all these changes honestly
i think if they would have done all of
this that would have been enough to amp
up the community with cross play and
with the uh other changes they're making
to to re
um
kind of breathe new life into the to the
trouse playlist but
now there will definitely be a lot more
people with matchmaking so i'm
interested to see how that goes
q
[Music]
e
uh i mean for me it all sounds appealing
because if i especially if like i try
matchmaking i get a few wins here and
it's going to give me a reason for me to
dabble in the playlist even if it's just
like a weird hour nobody's on and i just
kind of do my own thing for a little bit
i think it'll be a way for me to play
this probably more than i ever do
because if i go jump in
despite you know travis may hate the
fact that i can but if i jump in in my
little solo playlist then i can get
matchmade for a couple wins you know
then i might actually jump in there and
actually get something out of it because
honestly i haven't played trials in ages
so for me it's just like as even chat
saying are you actually going to play
i'm like you know i probably might
dabble just because it's one of those
things that's just gonna be you know if
a three person stacks on or i don't want
to go look and i you guys usually say
you have groups and if i asked you guys
i probably could but half the time
whether i'm making content or whatever
it's like hey i just want to do a
crucial match while videos editing or
something like that hey let me go in
let this thing render go
do my thing and then it's just a way for
me to
mess with the mode but without being
you know quite as much in-depth prep on
it
they do have a couple labs planned
though for season 15
capture and elimination hybrid um so one
point one capture point activates 30
seconds after each round starts with an
extended capture timer the capture load
check location changes each round as do
spawn locations capturing it wins the
round or you can just do elimination as
well
so that'll probably move people around
you got trials freelance that's a
separate one
basically everybody's solo we know how
freelance works and then they say no
intro quests one week when are players
who have never played in the crucible
can play
i don't know the purpose in that as a
labs thing that's because it made you it
made you uh
yeah made you play some other modes
before you could jump into trials it
would sound like you're not ready to
play this game yet there was like there
was like a quest that you had to do if
you hadn't played enough crucible games
like us like in theory though that's the
one that i'm like that's the one that i
will say probably shouldn't be there
because generally like you should
probably play a few reasons you're more
accessible e i mean i get that but you
should probably click on one crucible
node before trials is your first one
because you're going to go in there else
is just casual now it's like casual yeah
it's just casual totally okay
and yeah yeah
no no mike and it'll be great who cares
right accessibility
was like it's all accessibility hey
while we're making crucible and trials
more accessible can i have a
recommendation to make things less
accessible not that i've not done that
enough already on this show here's my
proposal here's my proposal yes please
remove matchmaking from gambit
i want it to be harder to get into a
gambit match so that there's fewer
reasons for me to have to play that mode
hey because playing if freelance gambit
match sucks playing gambit of the
randoms is a horrible experience most of
the time
and because it'll make me less likely to
play gambit that's my proposal oh there
we go is that is that your budget please
this week is that your bungee please
i don't want to play it as much oh my
god
what are we going to do with him
our child is academy
seriously
i'm just going to turn travis's volume
down he's gonna be like screaming and
banging on the screen and he's gonna be
in timeout over there
like i'm behind glass yeah i just put up
a little bars on his little uh section
he'll just be in jail
i have one one point to say on travis
thing but i'll talk about it when we get
to the seasonal stuff
because it kind of relates to that more
than it does to gambit but it's the same
problem that gambit has
interesting so we'll talk about it we
talked about it last night
well
i know you're talking about so that does
pretty much wrap up trials for at least
a half a second but before we go much
farther something else got a revamp that
i did not expect was that 90 minutes
right
no we're finishing this thing tonight
the rest of this stuff shouldn't be
quite as long
i hope but
we do have travis in here so it's fine
wow
travis had the shots and killed
it's just casual now it's totally fine
but you was deserving one yeah he never
throws a shot so that was actually good
that was pretty good
no sir did you guys see zer this weekend
yeah yeah
what did you guys think about the loot
yeah he's got random rolled weapons like
seven of them he's got a set of armor
for each class
those exotics are still the same those
are away they know the purpose of that
one but literally seven random world
weapons and a set of armor that the
hunters made out like a bandit i would
say like if you were if you were a new
hunter
you could do pretty well last weekend so
what'd you guys think of just that quick
change while we're in the world of
revamps at the moment
i've been confused about zurich's role
in the game for like two years helping
three years it's like helping new
players build up their exotic collection
that's literally the purpose
yeah but yeah i i i don't have any
thoughts about this i saw that and i was
like oh that's cool i guess and then i
forgot that it existed i i've seen zero
like three times in the past three years
like i see him like almost never he and
i have an appointment every week so
that's fine yeah teddy what about you
um yeah i mean this is a positive change
and d1 okay so zero's overall function
is to help people complete their exotic
collection uh and in d1 they added a
functionality i think with rise of iron
where you could re-roll the exotics with
the classes which was cool and i want
them yes yes
he's largely been kind of pointless
besides the like you know this is how
new players get the exotics especially i
think in year one he was more helpful
um it was but since then
it's kind of been whatever
um
i would just check him every week to get
my my one you know paid exotic random
engram and then and then i'd use my
exotic cipher as well which leads me
into a thing if any bungie employee is
listening there's a bug that was
introduced with the last season where
because i carried the quest over from
zur from the previous season season of
the chosen i cannot redeem my exotic
cipher cipher every week so please uh
fix this i still can't do it it's three
seasons of this yeah
i was like i'm probably in the same boat
i just haven't tried to use it so crap
yes i'm in the same boat i don't know
exactly what it is overall like this
this is a cool um
it's a cool thing for them to do um
i there's some data mine stuff that
people saw on like what other sets and
stuff he's going to have which
it's it's smart of them to
to um
to do this because it kind of gives him
a better purpose would i like him to
have other functionality sure but like
i've seen the suggestion thrown around a
lot which is uh have him sell old
cosmetics for like like quests oh okay
okay that that's come up often when
people talk about zur it's like oh have
him sell like the season one
eververse cosmetics but have it be like
a quest or some objective tests are you
having that oh that's not happening no
no everybody said that yeah
i don't care if you're with the nine but
everest got the power you don't sorry
bud oh she's a she's a high goddess
herself
they'll probably give her a zero 2.0 and
they'll be micro transactions
you have to grind for zur weave or
something i was gonna say how many how
many uh
strange coins how many new currencies
are we gonna get for zur that's fine
yeah mm-hmm
good times yeah i mean if teddy bear was
done i was i'll jump yeah yeah i'm done
it's positive like it's i'm gonna pull
up for travis i just wrote my eyes on
this i was like
like
okay you know
i forgot whose video i think shout out
to kakis i think i watched this video on
it i was just like they're putting in
legendaries you know i guess you know
maybe one week you know when it favors
specific you know um
you know uh play styles or for warlocks
high recovery on something or whatever
you know there's gonna be some of those
weeks that yeah certain things would be
fine it just you know he to me he's just
not for the hardcore he to me he's not
for us he's just he's literally oh he's
literally the exotic collection guy the
guys that hey i'm just playing destiny i
have no exotics i can't compete right so
now i go to him you trade in your shard
and stuff like that you know they still
need to figure out something i feel for
the um the hardcore community for them
and they they still seem to be torn i
was very curious to hear what teddy was
going to say about the data buys if he
was willing to share but nope just go
ahead and blow it past that one what
yeah
they're just i won't say what sets they
are but there's just other sets that the
other sets okay
so yeah i mean you know hopefully do
that and um i would like
one frustration i have on a cosmetic
level even though i know tess would not
agree with this is
i get frustrated when ornaments go away
or like it's but very limited window and
there's some really cool ornaments i'm
like damn i like when can i get that
like you remember the new monarchy um
you could only get the eyes of tomorrow
ornament from that action
bro i'm like when is this ornament
coming back so it's just like you know
i'd even do a quest for the damn
ornament whatever they want me to do
like hey some things you had to be there
for that's where some things are going
to live oh so you're going you're going
to foam on me you're going to
foundation rallies
which they literally wrote out the game
yeah like
if you if you were there for factionals
you got them if not too bad
wow some of those things
thanks for your accessibility no problem
absolutely that's why i'm here
travis is over there just like
it was just accessibility to say i
logged into my titan and i'm like okay
and then i'm checking zer watch on
twitch to see what they got in there on
their hunter i'm like they're going
through the hundreds like 60 61 62 65
i'm like damn i go on my titan 51 55 50
40 so i'm like
this past week so
every so often sir will be like hey
there's this hunter helm it's a good
helm and it's got like a 67 perfect snap
roll but other than that yeah it's
random luck that he'll have something
good for hardcore players like once
every six months other than that again
but if like there was a hunter who
jumped on and they're like you know
they've been playing a little bit but
they haven't you know been around a
season pass that many times and they
jump in and they're like dude these all
literally have 60 for
okay it may not be perfect rules but
that's a higher total than they probably
had for a little bit like that's decent
for them then you can go deeper into
like okay i want these stat rules and
stuff but if they bump up their totals
that's gonna help them a little bit so
overall i was just like it was a baby
quality of life but i was like kind of
appreciate that every so often there's
probably going to be a legendary that's
like okay this is the god roll in this
weapon make sure you buy it like
but not often just like anything else
yeah enough um okay so now we've got to
open the can of worms which i don't know
how long this one is gonna take um
season of the lost four hours
season of the lost so
we haven't touched this thing last week
at all we got witch queen we knew we had
the trailer for season to lost but we
haven't had a whole lot to talk about on
this one because or we have a lot to
talk about we haven't got there yet so i
wanted to get you guys just like how's
the season going for you so far before
we go into activities and other stuff
how's the season been
since we're like two weeks in now
basically we're to our steam games
oh overall i like it um i think i said
this last week but it's it's just kind
of more of the same but this time the
actual story stuff
justin has this problem where
there's all these side stories and they
do tie in somehow to the main
overarching story of destiny but
sometimes it's not immediately obvious
or like they have to play it out over
the course of literal years and so this
season i think is more impactful because
this is an actual like
main story beat that happened like we
were allegedly tying up the forsaken
stuff and and it's kind of finally you
know culminating into something
obviously the other season is like there
was there's a build up there and there
is there's connections but it's just not
as obvious um oh so overall i'm enjoying
it i am getting a little bit fatigued by
the
the sort of drip feed seasonal model
that we're having and i think it's
really going to get exacerbated this
season because of how long the season is
granted we have the anniversary pack to
kind of like hold this over after the
first three months but like
um
yeah we'll see how it plays out but
the seasonal activity so this is what i
want to touch on travis was mentioning
how poor and experienced gambit is and i
can sort of explain objectively why that
is so in destiny the average player
who's just completing bounties or doing
whatever
they're not thinking about
they're not min maxing every second of
how they play
so
when you enter something like the new
seasonal activity which has objectives
the enemies spawn infinitely in that so
there can be players that just shoot
enemies forever and never do the
objective and that can make the
experience miserable if you're the one
trying to complete just you know trying
to get through it
i've had a couple runs like that where
i'm the oh i'm i've carried all six
balls up the hill and it's it's just
terrible like it's not a fun experience
and everyone else is just shooting ads
um
gambit suffers from the same problem but
i think it's even more
in that because there's so many
different levels or layers of uh things
you need to do
uh in order to progress the game mode
uh properly so the activity
aesthetically i think looks amazing but
the
the way that it uh plays is just
in practice i think it's not fun uh but
overall like cool stuff i'm happy that
stuff is happening um
the weapons aren't that interesting to
me honestly
i think they're kind of whatever
um
the umbrella tier three focusing lockout
is really silly and the fact that it was
not locked out for the first
uh couple days and they server side
patched it is really scummy
uh just let me focus tier threes
especially because the cost is really
the seasonal cap on the materials
um especially because of the cost of
focusing
in pandora's box right now so yeah there
we go we just got about six topics on
the table where do we start
i mean
that's all i want to say essentially for
that
i think uh i think this is
it's already it hasn't even been two
full weeks since this came out and i
think it's already the best uh season
the best non-expansion season oh
spice and i think that i think that for
a couple reasons and i'm not trying to
just like be like oh yeah every season's
the best i love destiny so much like
genuinely i've i've not
this past seasons have not really
clicked with me the same way they have
with other players like menagerie i
think is really
overrated i and i don't mean that like
is it's bad i just think people
associate really good memories with that
season because it was so rewarding and
it was like oh the first time you could
like focus farm and everybody was like
obsessed with that but in terms of
redoing the same six person activity
where you're kind of just running around
doing like weird objective things i
don't really like any of those i i
didn't like the sundial i didn't like
menagerie i mean menagerie was was
definitely one of the better of the six
activities but like so many of these
have been so
uninteresting to me and it's it sucks
that every season it's just like okay
we're gonna get some random activity
that feels like a public event but has
like a a playlist to it and then it's
going to be there for a while and then
it's going to be gone and so
the reason that this season separates it
from me yeah is not because of the six
person activity it's because of the
shattered out of them the shattered
realm
is awesome it is like teddy and i were
doing it last night and i was kind of
like writing a love letter to it while
we were on in party chat like uh the
fact that it feels like a metroidvania
where you're unlocking different levels
by gaining powers as you level it up is
fantastic and the fact that we're gonna
presumably in two weeks we're gonna go
back to that first area but we're gonna
have new powers and be able to unlock
new areas is amazing and i i've just
been having so much fun with that i love
that they reused old assets but made it
feel new by putting it in this weird
ascendant plane i love that they like uh
time gated these different powers that
were unlocking and made it feel like a
cool metroidvania game where we're
unlocking true ascendant powers it's
awesome dude like when i got truesight
yesterday i was like oh there's so many
possibilities i can't wait to go back to
the first ascended area and do all the
uh puzzles i love that some of the
puzzles you can solve early if you're
clever enough teddy and i were opening
chests that we definitely were not
supposed to be able to get to yeah the
two in the second week because there's
an enigmatic one this week you kind of
gotta tweak a little bit before yeah we
got the enigmatic one that you're not
really supposed to access uh yet which
was awesome um i think that's fantastic
and then the other big thing for me is
that we finally have a villain that is
talking directly to us and doing
character building and we know she's not
going to die this season which is
so
good like zevo wrath is like a villain
that i feel like i didn't even meet like
i agree
like it's such a nothing burger of a
villain and i feel like that a lot like
a lot of the things we were fighting
were just like an idea like oh that ship
is gonna crash into the tower better not
let that happen by
lighting satellites or whatever the heck
we were doing and all that stuff where
it's just like so like such a bummer of
an activity feels really low stakes you
always feel disconnected with a story
this time we actually have the villain
talking directly with us in our midst
there's lots of like espionage going off
and and and we know that she's going to
be the main villain and so like the the
the threat is really present and i i
just absolutely love that so for the
story reasons and for the fact that
there's something beyond the six player
matchmade activity which i agree with
everything teddy said i don't think that
that mode is particularly fun but it's
it's not the reason i really like this
season so i think this is i think this
is the be at least for me for the things
i care about this is my favorite season
so far uh that isn't a main expansion
and i hope that they
uh use this as a model going forward
because that whole
reusing old stuff and making it feel new
every week by making a kind of like
progression like that's the right way to
do time getting like as opposed to what
they're doing with the
uh focus uh two three engrams and all
that stupid time getting stuff
this is the right way to to time gate so
i love it man i i i really am enjoying
the season so far cog
yo um good points good points made
um yeah the story's been fantastic you
know i've been really really enjoying
you know marisol and and going in there
and then obviously decided doing
conversations and the whole i'm your
friend i helped you i i did this
remember that video this week was
amazing
bro it was it was so good you know i
gave you a forum that you would like to
talk to you know what i mean like that
was
that was cold man it's i gotta rest the
piece for me they don't look good but
you don't say it but i didn't think
about it it looks spooky as hell it
doesn't but it's so
well done that like man i love it but um
yeah so you know the narrative is always
going to be it you know astral what is
it astral alignment is what it's called
the first one the six player um
mixed
because my first appearance which is bad
like i mean when i launched i don't know
if you guys had this experience where
like my debut playing the mode it
launched into the battery stuff and they
were like no batteries and
people just sitting there and shooting
around at nothing and i'm like what is
up today that was yeah that was my first
experience and i got it like three out
of four experiences and i was like what
and i had to keep going to orbit i'm
like what is going on so then when i
finally experience where mara is talking
to you you go into the blind well i'm
like oh this is what's supposed to
happen so that i got into it you know
maybe i'm a little biased towards i do
kind of like six player activities i
don't feel this is like the greatest but
i i like i like the attempt at some
simple mechanics of the battery up the
hill and you know moving all right guys
you know get behind me relay race tag
team you know whatever simple enough
that blueberries can get in
and do something you know kind of thing
and then the boss i did i do like this
though i do like
you know when they do six player
activities and it's not the same bosses
every week and i i do like that we got
the new boss the guy that was kind of
like getting the ether to scoring
whatever whatever shout out to some
scoring champions i was very happy to
see that that was cool we knew those
were coming but yeah they're fun
that was fun listen it's just simple now
to trash point he's 1 000 on the money i
was pleasantly surprised with the
shattered realm that
took me by surprise and i think this is
the good balance that i feel season of
the splicers set up which is like you
have your your main activity whatever
which you know the the the one when you
jump up the thing that one wouldn't have
fun but you also have this other
contained experience which i feel
shattered realm does and it really gave
me the haunted house vibes and you know
doing the anchors the searching around
like you said the metroidvania this
closes up this portal secrets and then
to me this the overall why this season
works is i got shout out paris out
besides the laws fire we have to admit
the dreaming city is still one of the
most fantastic creations they've ever
done
and every time even when i'm playing
astro alignment i'm smiling i'm looking
at that beautiful scape in the back when
i'm doing you know shattered realm i'm
looking at the
you know how it is e like when you do
shattered throne just the environment
alone you're like yo
you don't say you're in this dark
ascendant play like it just it feels
good so it's just i'm gonna be sad if
you know most likely this is gonna
probably get vaulted you know the rumors
are that this you know the curse will
break it it's gonna go but i wanna give
the dreaming city its roses while it's
here it is the most phenomenal
probably space that they've created
to me definitely getting put it's
definitely getting put in the vault and
that's what i want to give roses down
before we we pour it out we break this
curse and whatever and the last point
you know i'll say is that you know the
um the focusing cool but e you know
we've had this conversation
i cannot stand this new thing with the
what is it the 1500 cap on
the thing because it's bad enough yeah
it's bad enough that you capped it right
but then you can't cap it to that price
and then the expense of the tier 2 and
the tier 3 focusing rips you apart so
it's like come on you got to give us a
little bit reward the people who are
still grinding and playing these
playlists playlist activities that that
really grant you them in bulk right so
like what it is is they're just showing
me they are artificially extending this
thing as long as they can
you know parallax currency thank you
yeah that that that it's really limiting
like really because what is it like the
cost of one of them i think a tier two
is gonna be like six hundred
yeah that's way too much
some of the
they all use the same currency too so
upgrading your actual compass also costs
this currency and you can run out after
two percent yes and i don't like that i
hate
that the game they started this with
splicer i hate that they use the same
currency for focus engram that they do
for actually doing the actual unlocks
you know i hate
it i really bothered to be that that's
my only complaint yeah i'm curious
oh yeah i mean you guys have touched on
a lot of stuff i mean else since we're
on the kind of currency
like wall hell
um
yeah it was just like you had the tier
three focuses i was like oh four but i
clicked on one i was like oh that's
still there and then they're like oh
we're fixing that i'm like i was
literally live and new new rad was even
sitting there talking to me like hey
make sure you guys uh focus those before
they patch them and i saw it was
literally done server side not even an
hour later after he said it he's like
rip
so it's like that's what and this is the
season where you can grind that stuff
reasonably you get 100 and crucible you
get 150 in strikes you can actually get
a decent amount but what if you have
that whole like hey i do i could get
that streak bonus in strikes now well if
you do 10 strikes
and you're gonna be getting some as you
kill people you just hit the capacity
and one of those is going to be a waste
so it's like it's too small of a limit
first off yes
yeah way too small wait like 1500 when
you give me 150 in a strike is too damn
small i'm sorry like double well i don't
know why there's a cap on it
so i mean they limit you
you get like 110 and crucible i think it
might be the best way to grind them
crucible bro i was playing bamboo i
don't know yeah i got mad at myself
i capped out and i forgot to cash out
and i'm just exactly earning any more
continue yeah no but that's the thing is
like you can if you get in just an iron
banner run with people playing hold on
we gotta go back to the helm i gotta
turn in some i gotta turn in some
umbrellas right now because i'm i'm full
up and everybody's like we were in a
good list man what are you doing to us
and it's like you you're gonna run out
of space like that's a limitation on go
by the tower go by the tower go by the
helm like
that's not necessary
because when you go to the compass
you're already limited please reach step
seven in the quest please reach
step five or like rank five on the
compass go reach step 17 on the first so
go reach step 27 i was like that's going
to be like week six
and i just can't
i can't grind it out if i want to
and then the other other
quick question quick question sorry to
interrupt you oh how do you feel when
you did that when you did the quest and
it literally tells you that it hit me
harder than all three that hit me hardly
oh 53 was one no but it's like when you
get to the step quest this will be
available next week to reset and i know
it's done it every week but the fact
that it will be available on weekly
reset was in text and i read it
a little more than it has before for
some reason i'm like the fact that i can
read it and you're just like it's like a
big ass stop sign
just like
it's like here's the quest oh you're on
step six stop
next week okay you can go again
stop
yeah that's how it like green light
pretty much
100 it's red light green light on that
damn 53 step quest and i was like
i almost liked it i thought it was a i
thought that was a bug when it said 53
steps i was like i did for a second i
was like
yeah i got when i got to the stop sign i
was like oh that's why they just put it
all in one quest this time i almost
liked it better like last season when
you did like the four steps and then it
faded you're like oh we'll do another
thing next week and it had like a
different name now they just kind of
smashed it into one is like and here's
your weekly wall that you know you're
and it's like step 53 i'm like okay so
that's about 10 weeks cool
but it's like you know exactly what's
coming um
any of the seasonal activities i guess
talked about the six-person matchmaking
ones sundial and menagerie
big six-person match made ones and then
recently we've had things like how many
times you're gonna run expunge how many
times you're gonna run override
especially override um but any of these
things as much as they make us run them
they all wear thin it doesn't seem to
matter which one we're doing some hand a
little better than the others like
season of arrivals doing a public event
season of worthy doing a public event
those were roughest i would say
um as travis says so worth in for me
like on the second one yeah the second
one i was like i'm over this already
yeah i was like for sundial we had three
different i wish there was a little more
boss variation like i thought when
sundial came out like we were gonna go
there was like a boss section of each
time area but it's like nope go back to
this place and still fight the same boss
the ending boss was kind of cool but
like
they've all had their ups and downs
menagerie had a lot of variety but then
same thing when you've done it twice
you've done most of the rooms then you
might see one new one
um
but also with menagerie i think a lot of
people forget that like it was very
rewarding because you could run back and
forth and do the extra turn-ins and then
and then when they nerfed that then
everybody's like oh this is a bit more
all like 20 minute run for like one
chest type thing so it didn't they left
it on though purposefully remember they
they told us oh we're going to fix that
later on this date so get your runs in
there right
so yeah that was part of why that thing
was so fun everybody's like huh run run
do it again set it up run back do it
again get really efficient at those
things and that was going to be that a
guardian con
that they patched it during guardian
call and i was playing at night on my
laptop with the people i was staying
with and yeah and then they patched it
that week yeah
rip and as forecast said like certain
like
menagerie with five new lights was rough
yeah you'd be in you couldn't fail the
normal version at least
so
yeah that one could take a little while
but you couldn't fail it you just might
see a lot of encounters so i mean this
for me you guys know i love shatter
throne they're not shadow throne uh
shadow drum you know i'm gonna love that
because of the stuff i like i love the
dungeons i love doing that stuff by
myself
you know i've been going youtube tour
tutorials i've been making youtube
guides where every anchor is where every
chess is at how can i make the most
efficient run for all of the anchors
from start to finish and go through and
do that stuff but also for me it's like
as you said i didn't like quite make the
connection of the metroidvania of like
hey here's this thing i knew it at the
time i was like hey this thing and then
here's safe passage and truth that is
like we're going to come back here on
week four
and we're going to do it again but we're
going to get to do like the first week
now we're going to have safe passage and
we're going to have truesight so the
first one is gonna look completely
different by the time we get back there
the only thing is then when we get to
about week six then you're like all
right now i've done it all
but then you're gonna have to keep doing
it so like that's the a six month season
again the 30
you know the 30th anniversary stuff is
gonna help a little bit for that like
shot in the arm in about december when
it's gonna come which is when we're all
gonna be tired of it
um
but i will say i think
the fact that there's two different
variations of like astral alignment
gives a little flux the weekly bosses as
well there's enough rotation in there if
you do it a few times that you need to
it's not too bad if you're grinding out
for like powerfuls and you're gonna do
like nine of them that's gonna be a
while but for me it's like if i do a
couple times move the quest forward
mostly okay
but what do you guys think about the
here's if i if i had a six month season
the way i would have done this event is
i would have made you do all three
ascendant worlds without any of the
powers and then at the end of the third
week i would have given you barrier
break or whatever barrier
you do all three again with barrier
breach and then you get truesight at the
end of that three weeks cycle and then
you do it again and then you get uh you
know safe passage and then the fourth
week you get or the fourth run through
you get to do all three again
with uh all of your powers because that
would have been what 12 12 weeks
12 weeks and you could have that's how i
would have done it if i was really
trying to stretch it so i guess we
should kind of be glad that they're
giving us one power a week that seems
generous yeah i was gonna say the way
you described that sounds almost
painfully slow that's like hey here's
your metroid game that you get like play
level one week one but yeah you're gonna
play the level one three two yeah but
every but every playthrough would be
would feel completely different because
imagine come right just completely the
first one yeah three the first three
with no powers and you're just seeing
everything and you're like i have no
idea what is supposed to happen here
yeah if they stretch it that long i
think this is about the right balance i
think you're right if they had done that
um
because i mean you could run through
that and you can see
where some of the things are gonna go
and you're like all right i gotta wait
four weeks just to do barrier i gotta
wait seven weeks just to get back here
with true sight safe passage like that
would have stretched it too long like
once a week on these and then coming
back like then four five and six being
like the other piece of fresh
that's about as far as i think it should
be stretched but i think it does give it
just of enough life that six is a
reasonable balance because 12
yeah that would have been that would
have been like
yeah that 53 step quest almost feels
good now
by the time you did it that many times
i wonder yeah because i i wonder if it
would feel better to do a 12-week
process where every week felt different
because you had new powers
or
if doing it a six-week process and then
you just have to arbitrarily do it again
with the exact same powers because it
seems like with a 53 uh step quest it's
not gonna be done in six weeks right or
do you think it will be no that'll be
about a ten week thing and i think we'll
be going six weeks but i was like unless
they do some other variations unless
there's something on like weeks eight
night but i mean when we did expunge we
only only had six variations then we
still repeated that for a little while
so i was like i think they can only give
certain pieces of content so much legs
like i'm imagining there's only going to
be three bosses for astral alignment
we've seen two of them but it also said
in the triumph that there's actually two
bosses in the triumph so i don't even
know if there's any more wow
so we've seen them all the the boss this
week is cool though yeah yeah this week
yeah i did yeah i like the voices
um
gk is asking teddy did you like any of
the new content do you like shattered
realm do you like the i know like
shattered realm is that doing anything
for you or
yeah like travis basically hit all the
points we were talking about this last
night it's it's just metroidvania i
think i think that
game design
is so good like almost any game that
does that is it's just very smartly done
um and especially in destiny's case
whether they're constantly reusing
assets to save on development time and
give us something new so they they they
look just really what travis said they
they took a shatter the ascendant realm
uh filter
and then slapped on the earth assets and
the tangled shore assets and kind of you
know they broke them up a little bit
made some loading platforms there's some
new stuff in there it's not all entirely
reused
but then you also have this um
it's almost like a true open world
like destiny has patrol but besides the
dreadnought in the dreaming city you
don't really
like do a whole lot on patrol
it's just you know it's it's free roam
but
you know whatever
the besides the two end game
destinations where there's actual
secrets and like things to unlock and
things to do and so it's kind of cool to
have that
you know you see something and you know
it it's that
the star wars jedi fallen order effect
or the metroid prime where it's like you
see that and you're like i know i can go
there later but you can't do that or
zelda does this as well when you see the
workshop thing and you're like yes oh
yeah i know that's a hook shot but i
can't go there right now
later
and so yeah the shadow realm is awesome
um
there is some data mind stuff that i
won't spoil in the triumphs that that
show more stuff coming for that later um
nice nice that that will kind of give us
uh a reason to go back to it nice we've
unlocked everything so
uh that'll be cool i'm assuming when it
comes up and for cotto pointed out
there's a legendary version of astral
alignment for something
that's gonna be right nice
i remember seeing that in the traps
that's big for me because yeah and
that's the other piece we haven't
actually mentioned is the
uh stasis trace rifle that's going to be
coming from all these atlas skis we've
been getting on a weekly basis which
those in themselves have very cool
lore when you sit there and listen to
the story between the brother and the
sister
and like you know the relation to
obviously aldrin and mara and she's
talking about that listening to his old
stories as kind of as he was older and
before i really kind of how they're
doing that just kind of how it's
delivered you know it's like 200 minute
countdown timer when you get to the end
you listen to the lore and then you're
done and the other skus aren't that hard
to find they're like basic clues they're
like one was like garden waterfall i'm
like well i know exactly where that's
gonna be
but there was one on um what was the
first destination
where were they both in dreaming oh one
was just uh oh the first one was the
first the villian mists yeah um yeah one
of those was just like staring me square
in the face but just took me a minute to
figure out so they haven't been too bad
on the clues once you get close um
but i'll be curious i really liked it
you don't have to do guides or anything
the clues are specific enough to where
if you played around in the dreaming
city you sort of know where all these
are yep it's kind of great
yeah but i'll be curious if that exotic
has like a cool
if we do get another pressage if we do
get another harbinger if we get a quest
related to
like here's the atlas skus and then it
looks like there's a portal sitting in
the middle of the room then once you got
the portal open do you go through that
for the quest or how's that gonna work
i'm actually kind of very intrigued to
see how that all plays out
because we're due for an exotic quest
especially but also if we get a trace
rifle i don't expect that to have random
rules so then the replayability is
something i wonder about as well if we
do get it is it a one time thing
like a whisper or is it gonna be because
they said they weren't gonna have every
weapon be random which i don't want them
all to be
um
but again it does give that replay value
granted i do some of those for pinnacles
now but again the exotic quest
we know it's coming they've obviously
shown the stasis trace rifle
right is that something you guys are
excited about or is it just like yep
it's another color trace rifle it's
going to be there is that something you
guys are hoping you know is this going
to be your mr freezer type thing
yeah i'm curious i want to see you know
what they do with it this is um
i think teddy kind of alluded to how i
feel with the weapons to see it's been a
mixed bag for me because
you know
laurence was oh my god that thing was it
was tearing it was causing terror i mean
in the pvp they were tearing me up i was
like what is going on i and now i didn't
know why
so that caught the wrath as far as to do
exotic yeah trace rifles you know we we
when we ran the gamut on elements i'm
curious to see what they do with that as
far as i mean you know cold heart was
that you know what is it um
yeah prismatic lens and then they had
the the void one that i i don't think
i've ever shot even before i think i
have it i've never shot that one ever
splitter wave splitter yeah that was the
playstation yeah yeah that was the
exclusive but i have it so you know i'm
you know going to see what that is i
think
where my issue is
this is the first time i'm kind of like
these new perks are like
like i i didn't really see anything like
the stasis one where you should get the
headshot and it
yeah you turn into it you turn into the
odds of the perks the perks the perks
like i'm the the the new gun perks have
been very
niche to me like very
you know there's one now what is it 80
iago they're supposed to give you like
yeah whatever extra damage then it's
like this one where it's like i call it
what is the travis perks where it's like
you know
shoot this then do that with your
primary
on the thursday
behind this corner of the dream big city
and then you're gonna get plus five and
i'm like you know it just yeah they're
moving
stuff towards that more um there was a
recent um uh
podcast i forgot what podcast was
they talked about
going forward kind of their design
choices with a lot of perks and
different aspects of destiny yeah and
they want trade-offs for basically
everything or um
things that you have to do x action to
trigger the thing yeah in the last few
seasons a lot of the products have
introduced
it's that right like you have to do this
kind of specific thing that you're maybe
doing here and there um personally i
don't like that i just want you know i
want up time like the best friends are
always gonna be the ones that just have
to do it
right like frenzy right like frenzy just
activates because i'm just doing the
thing i do in every single situation of
destiny
um
so
yeah sorry that's all no i mean
literally i mean you know just i don't
know how i feel i know what your guys
experience with a lot of these new perks
but i remember seeing a couple of them
and i was just like you know eh you know
kind of thing i will say
um i know i'm diverging into weapons and
stuff like that but i will say i do like
i don't know if any of you guys got the
gambit 260 scout yep i know i like that
a search survey servant leader servant
later yes yes
yes
and it's got i got a kill clip um what
you call a killing wind roll right now
that i'm liking so i'm like okay that's
cool it's going to be in that bottom
dollar rng again but you know how they
do you play a bunch of matches the perk
pool is insane and the perk pool's
insane so god bless y'all what y'all
trying to get i was very fortunate to
get this thing but um yeah for the most
part the you know what got me the most
excited not the perks not that
traveler's chosen catalyst
i am potent
bro that's great i like it full auto and
now or osmosis with it and then it was
already savage with just killing so many
people and like for me what that likes
to run a stasis build with high up time
on my abilities bro shooting this stuff
charging it up getting my stasis melee
my my what you call it my freeze rift
and and all that stuff like and the
grenade like i'm
loving travelers chosen right now so
sidearms making a little you know making
me feel good that's pretty much it i
want to know how you guys feel about
perks you know weapons or anything you
guys liked for the season
uh yeah perks kind of whatever like it's
until somebody shows me a video with
objective evidence that like one of
these perks is
good for a gm or a master vog then i'm
just not going to use them follower yeah
yeah
i mean for like me there's one i swear
every other gonna get has ensemble on it
and as i play my by myself half the time
i'm like
not really going to help me right now
like
so ensemble is like handling a reload
speed and allies are nearby i'm like
reload speed and a grand master if
you're sitting in a group and you can
sit there and just like you know
basically probably have like field prep
or something it's not a bad thing but
again what are you taking away it's like
i know they're getting away from some of
the perks but
yeah it's just weird
i got it
they
brought back salute yes i do have one
requested perk forever and they finally
brought it back um so i am happy about
that because for for solo content or
um i i mean even just general play like
it's just it's just a good perk
especially if like the gun
only has like one good perk in the in
one column and shoot to loosen the other
one then that's
that's perfect nice so nice that's one
like positive i guess yeah traps any
weapons any perks anything stand out
that you're excited or just like
it's weird getting um
stasis guns to drop in the kinetic slot
yep uh that's like my first thing that
i've just been like trying to
cope with like i'm like all right i need
to like figure out how this is going to
affect my sandbox but
um yeah i agree with the perks stuff or
sorry perks yeah perks i'm just
wondering like is there going to be a
big
like perk sunset at some point because
how are any of these niche perks going
to compete with like
ram pages that always apply yeah rampage
and stuff so i'm wondering if they're
gonna
do not a sunset but a they're gonna like
tweak all of the existing uh overpowered
perks to make them function differently
which they've done in the past and uh
if that i think it'll it'll make the uh
the new i actually think
the only reason the new perks are bad is
because the old ones exist but if the
old ones that were broad and always
worked were not in existence i actually
think i would prefer
the the new model it's just it's only
bad in context of the fact that the
existing perks exist but if they didn't
shame sunset
yeah let you build a weapon based around
what you want to do with it and how you
play that sort of stuff but like it's
hard to do that with the temptation of
like hey there's these these broad perks
that just automatically always work for
you that that's my issue
i got one thing i forgot that i do like
the sun setting should have been a thing
we're not doing it we're not doing it
the mods are also good i like the mods
yeah so one thing i do like have you
guys been playing around with stasis
armor
i've been getting i've been slowly
acquiring some mods before i get in i
just don't have them all yet
some of the stasis armor mods
very powerful
i'm liking a lot of up time a lot of i'm
seeing a lot of unique things in the
stasis what i think for one right now
just i'm making a build i got this crazy
build right now where travelers chosen
and stay cis where i'm getting my uptime
on my abilities right and then i have um
there's a the stasis class item where
it's like if you the minute you lose
like a you use your class thing like it
automatically starts to recharge faster
or something like that it is a lot of
high up time stuff and very unique um
yeah stasis resist new red know what i'm
talking about bro there's a lot of stuff
in there which stasis arm i would highly
advise
change to um at least one of your pieces
or if you get a new piece two stasis and
then see what's available there now they
the only negative
is i believe they're pushing you away
from the charge with light stuff in the
final slot i'm sure they are yeah
because there are no are there any
charges with light stasis yeah yeah when
you go there they're not available right
yeah so they're pushing away from that
but
they have their own unique ones in the
middle slots the two middle slots that
are really good and i've been playing
around with the um
the re almost the auto reloader holster
generic ones that are in there for
everybody but yeah just some stuff to
consider just i would say get some
stasis armor and hold on to it there's
some unique stuff in there i mean you
can swap any piece to it as well just
like anything else anything but if you
don't want to use the mats i'm just
saying whatever yeah well i mean yeah
just do it early before well it's cheap
and it's not that big of a deal
yes uh thoughts about our new linear
fusion rifle buddy which just got a
little tweak for pvp for the better uh
but overall what do you guys think about
the lawrence driver
super fun
especially with the the artifact mod
the sound it makes when you get a head
shot is amazing yes
what does this
do
so the catalyst makes it so um
if you get enough of the stacks uh you
don't have to get a headshot to trigger
the explosion
um i think i think you only need three
oh wow
oh so like if you got the damage buff
then it works as like
any like a body shot would basically get
though invert like wow implosion
and uh it's
what is the catalyst what does the
catalyst do uh
dude it's so good it makes it do have it
more damage and then stability uh i
think when you're firing like full auto
when you're just oh when you're doing
full auto more damage
as opposed to the literal shape it mel
it melts people with almost zero flinch
or almost zero like recoil and then you
only need to get two kills in pvp before
you fully charge it with uh three uh
linear fusion bolts and those are one
shot yeah one shot headshots yeah bro oh
nice dude i've just been tearing tearing
people off
yeah yeah i go front it's it's it's kind
of the halves and they have knots
because when you got it
bro you tearing things up in this game
like the global changes they did this
season that affected it in fusion rifles
like it got a 40 damage buff in pve
which oh
my god it's just it's so usable now it's
actually fun bro and then that mod that
artifact mod with the with the um that
like
that like i don't even miss um what was
the breaching clear anymore i'm like
lineages are outside bro between that
um sleeper
and yo if you got a threaded needle with
vorpal shout out to cross you got a good
good video right now if you don't want
to use sleeper in that exotic slot you
got that bro you're right there on dps
you're not even that far i'm telling
y'all right now dust off or start
farming linears from i think that was
battlegrounds that linear yes it is yeah
yeah if you could get one with vorpal
bro and that mod and you free up your
exotic slot you eating baby you're
eating loving it also it can also do uh
auto loading yeah frenzy yeah i got i
think i got clown cartridge and um
vorpalomi yeah i was like i've got
frenzy and rapid hit on mine so it's
okay but
yeah it's good good nice
yeah but no vorpal for me um
so yeah we talked about you know
we had a rant over the world of trials
and then we cover season lost in
uh let's see
40 minutes is there anything else you
guys want to mention on season of the
lost so far oh no i just went out i was
like do not forget void 3.0 oh that's
next don't worry good okay
so with which queen as a lot of people
expected and then they confirmed we are
not getting a new green subclass as a
lot of people thought was gonna be
coming but
we are getting a revamp supposed to be
over like consecutive seasons probably
since there's only four there's probably
one off season uh but the light classes
are going to be reworked in the same
fashion we have stasis with aspects
fragments except this time they have to
deal with multiple supers as well
and as they did confirm an interview
before i go any farther they've also
said
you're not going to lose supers which
luke smith had potentially said might
have been it like
said hey nova bombs this iconic thing
nova warp might go away that's not gonna
be a thing anymore we're gonna they want
you to maintain all of your abilities
but more of a mix and match action
um so brave new world so
as you saw we're gonna be doing serious
revamp so the light subclasses in
destiny are void solar and arc
subclasses i wonder if they literally
state them in that order and that's the
order with what we're gonna get them
first then i wonder if it's going to be
solar and then arc um
so i mean some of those have been around
since 2014 so they said they are due for
a bit of a revamp so they said they're
going to start with void in season 16
with the launch of which queen and they
said they're going to give these things
a new shape basically the stasis has
like three words that they kind of live
by for their stasis subclasses
the final shape yes those three words
specifically
but they want each subclass to kind of
embrace a few terminologies for what
they use and it's going to work across
all the subclasses to kind of
work for both negative effects and then
positive effects so for void they want
to embrace status of negative status
effects of either suppression
weaken
or volatile
suppression the target is knocked out of
any active abilities same way you guys
know you suppress stuff now weaken
they take more damage and has their
movement slowed and then volatile the
target is afflicted with unstable void
energy and will explode upon taking
additional damage or on death so it
makes them kind of a ticking time bomb
three positive effects they're working
on void overshield protective barrier
void light which reduces damage taking
from combatants
invisibility
and devour
feast on energy uh from your foes kills
restore your health grant grenade energy
and extend devour
i really wish my titan could embrace the
world of devour but that might be a
little busted here we go with the titan
e-bag and continue no no my more mean is
like invisibility devour like
invisibility you go hunter over shield
you go this it was like if they really
like get into like fragments or anything
i don't know if they'll go that far
because i can like
invisibility is like a hunter thing
devours warlock thing shields obviously
titan thing but if they really let you
mix and match in the world of void
i don't know if they will but that would
definitely make things even spicier i
just don't know if they're gonna get
that far so based on an interview that
justin truman did yeah it sounds like
that is the case like all the classes
are gonna have see i wondered because he
said something about that with devour
right he was talking about that yeah he
said he was excited that devour i forgot
how he phrased it but basically it
implied that all classes are getting
that it's not just exclusive to it
making the game too accessible i i don't
like i want to have it to myself
i want accessibility
you should get it tattooed
yeah before forecasted as well it's like
they won't excel at everything but
you'll have access so there's gonna be
some synergies probably the warlocks are
probably still gonna be the best to
devour but in theory my titan might be
able to dabble with a fragment that
might do something
actually think that's so
great change use all the mechanics yeah
it really lets you kind of dabble maybe
get kind of a weird funky build for a
titan but you see a titan come and
you're like i don't even know what he's
going to do anymore because they have
all the customization which makes it fun
so night stalker hunter basically they
gave some examples of stuff they don't
go through every single detail
but they say for night stalker hunter
shadow shot mobius quiver super
fires two volleys of three void arrows
in a cone which seek out enemies and
spawn void anchors on impact shadowshot
makes tethered enemies volatile and
deals increased damage to tethered
targets one of the main usability pain
points of the current iteration of
mobius quiver is having to press the
super input a whole bunch of times to
fire each air individually some people
will be sad they can't fly by using it
but that's a thing
uh which is cumbersome takes a lot of
time often results in players drifting
somewhere they didn't intend to be which
i've definitely shot a super into a
ceiling
uh by firing multi arrows multiple
arrows at once it should be a lot easier
to blanket an area with traps in
preparation for a fight or put burst
damage on a boss so that one seems
pretty cool stylish executioner it's an
aspect
defeating a weakened suppressed or
volatile target grants invisibility and
true sight after performing a stylish
execution your next melee attack while
invisible weakens enemies
and then they said a twist on middle
tree nightstalker's current flawless
execution perk this aspect collects the
hunters specialize in defeating debuffed
enemies to keep looping their
invisibility
so i mean nice
thoughts
any
do you guys i mean
any hunter players specifically like
anybody in chat as well do you guys have
any thoughts of you know taking mobius
quiver into like two cones that you
would basically you know kind of the way
hunters throw two sets of knives it's
going to be two cones of arrows now
easier better we'll you know feel like
you're taking away control is it a good
thing
anybody have an opinion
yeah um thoughts
i think i think this is
like people have been asking since that
you came out to give us the d1
subclass tree but bungie has this thing
where when we request old things they
don't just like giving us
the whole thing they want to reinvent
and sometimes for better or worse that's
sort of just how it is and stasis was
definitely
or the way they did the stasis subclass
was definitely a test to see
um
could this work in other systems and i
think when luke smith said the thing he
said that
we were referencing i think they were
still trying to figure out i think that
was before before um
beyond light came out so i think they
were still trying to assess like how did
they approach this uh should we update
them should we just leave them the way
they are right and they definitely aged
and i mean to their credit they did
update various trees of each subclass
over the years like you know john blade
and all that
um
but this is just this is like way
overdue in my opinion like i think i
think this this needed to happen uh at
least a year ago at the very earliest
but i'm glad they're finally doing it
i'm glad they're going to roll out
slowly yeah it's not a uh it's not a
foster um cluck of of just
this crazy stuff uh going on because i
mean stasis was
clearly a challenge for them like
they've admitted that when they
introduced it yep um so so and then
they're very clear that when they're
gonna redo these they're going to
you know be careful about how they how
they do everything so i'm happy with
this stuff i mean
it's uh i'm bummed that solar is not
first because that means well's going to
get shafted for
uh for which queen but
you guys see how it's going out for us
trav you seem like you're bubbling
no i uh i think this is great i
i am encouraged by this i think it
needed to happen i'm surprised we're
getting it as soon as we are yeah and um
yeah i'm just
i'm excited to see how it works i think
void's a great place to start on the
titan side because titans definitely
need some love in the void category but
i think kind of all of the void
subclasses are
maybe i'm misremembering them but it
seems like i mean noble world
warlocks are probably now in the best
spot but they were previously
complaining about their void subclasses
all the time hunters have complained
about night stalker for a million years
and uh titans i think have never really
nailed the void subclass ever since the
introduction of the shield versus the
bubble yeah it almost seems that that
subclass almost seems primed for there
to be a
system similar to stasis because it's
trying to do something trying to do so
many things bubble and then also the
shield that you hold out and then also
the one you throw and hit things with
it's just like it's too many uh supers
all in once yeah i mean the biggest
excited to have that broken out i was
just getting the biggest thing for avoid
titan there's always the middle tree
if you get that void damage explosion
and then it starts chaining like you
throw the one grenade you get like just
the fireworks that's always the thing i
want to have equipped but you can't do
that in bubble well right sentinel titan
overwatch and this is actually going to
change it up too which is interesting
cast a void empowered barricade to grant
a void overshield to yourself and nearby
allies the empowered barricade slowly
regenerates the void overshield of
allies bunkering behind it
we want players to be able to lean into
the sentinel fantasy of being the
frontline protector for your team so
overwatch is a powerful tool for setting
up prior to an encounter and providing a
safe haven to fall back
to when things get spicy so they're
actually changing it sounds like i don't
know if bubble is actually going away
specifically
because they got just got done tweaking
it which is weird to where like you can
actually like kill the bubble pretty
easily if you don't have high resilience
but it does sound like overwatch is
going to be this new void wall that
buffs people around it as opposed to
a dome of safety which seems kind of
interesting also shield toss they said
projectile melee hero shield towards an
enemy the shield can ricochet off
enemies and surfaces granting we kind of
know how that works uh we want to give
titans more options when it comes to
projectile melees shield toss is a great
choice for aggressively pushing towards
a group of enemies softening them up and
giving you extra slaying power so
they're actually going to make the
shield toss like a projectile melee
and we haven't had that because picture
celestial fire for a warlock or
what's the supernova one that i always
gave you a hard time about i'm finally
gonna have
handheld supernova yeah yeah um but it's
cool like you know we're getting a
projectile melee that fits with the
subclass so it's like these are exciting
changes for everybody i think because
we're getting
flexibility and they're getting back to
subclasses they haven't touched in years
and as they said some of them since d1
have been pretty stuck
uh gotta get cog on this one the warlock
pocket singularity projectile melee
launch a tracking unstable ball avoid
energy that detonates when it's near
enemies pushing enemies away from the
blast and making them volatile design is
an anti-dive tool
which i still don't know if i understand
the wording of what that's doing and a
way to push enemies out of cover with
careful placement it's possible and
incredibly incredibly satisfying to
boop enemies up in the air and then pop
their pop their volatile with a
well-placed head shot before they hit
the ground i'm sure somebody's going to
have a buff of that
and they actually mention an aspect for
the warlocks for like the aspects and
fragments
so child of the old gods
cast your rift to summon a sentient
black hole which hovers at your side
waiting for a target it will launch
itself at enemies then begin siphoning
their energy and weakening them
refunding their life force this is true
i've never seen a lifesteal in this game
so that's actually kind of new
um back to you as either grenade or
melee energy oh so it's not actually
health
um if you're using healing rift or
health if you're using an empowering
rift so it's actually got some kind of
counter functionality to your rift nice
uh defeating enemies who are being
siphoned by the child by the child that
sounds weird by the child
we'll refund some rift energy child the
old gods is a strong debuff tool that
gives voidwalkers an additional way to
lock down an area while sustaining
themselves like they're going big on
this stuff and if this is just what
they're doing for void i mean solar and
arc like cannot get here soon enough in
my book they these just sound like
exciting changes the flexibility of just
even taking that you know void sentinel
and taking normally i want to bubble or
now the new big giant wall shield
whatever it's going to be but i want
things to explode when i hit them with
my void grenade you can finally do that
we've been asking for this forever as
opposed to tree one or tree two okay
and now it's like finally getting back
to that so i'm pumped about this because
this dives more into the rpg like make
your own build
yeah and to me if that's
for the people who love d1 that was part
of the fantasy right part of the fantasy
i'm not saying it necessarily executed
it all the way in d1 but part of the
fantasy was that you had some control
over the build and you can do that and i
think a lot of y'all like
you know admittedly since stasis has
dropped
it it released like
i use stasis a lot primarily in pve
almost to the point where it is really i
mean unless it's a rating you definitely
need you know a well radiance warlock
you know and lunafactions i'd be
grudgingly like all right guys i know
for this for the templar for the dps you
need me to do today you know i get it
because the situation calls for it but
i've been exclusively using stasis and
to the point where like controlling
points whether i use my frost poles to
for the riff freezing whether i use the
turret you know the stuff like i i i
feel like i have more control and
especially the aspects you know going to
specific play styles and and stuff like
that and to see 3.0 go further and push
limits and really add new mechanics and
new aspects that is super exciting to me
so yeah i love the i love the custom
customization aspect of it because i
feel like i can be diverse for different
activities and stuff like that so this
is great i i love all of this
gentlemen
travis teddy any i'm surprised to hear
you say you use pve stasis i i almost
never equipped it
i'm addicted to that then again titans
got pretty hard i was like yeah because
you know what yeah
honestly like is yeah only okay because
first you have to slam if you do the
super it's kind of directional it's not
this just like oh everything around me
is frozen now everything's exploded i
gotta go run up and bust everything i've
missed with my stasis with melee
probably as many times as i've hit
with that yeah cause the slidiness the
slidiness and then like depending on
when you let go of the trigger if you're
close enough or not something about that
just like the tracking they messed with
titan melee tracking in the first place
for like the charges
especially in pvp there's plenty of
times where i like should have hit and
probably didn't um and i know the auto
u-turn tracking is a thing but like
somehow that stasis melee for me and i
could just suck with it i get it but no
i heard the same thing i've messed a lot
with that titan melee and i'm like damn
i just tend not to use it
enough i i hate to say i think
i'll speak to eyes teddy i don't know
how he feels about it from with shade
binder but i just feel shaybat is so
versatile and then
i could like on grand masters i'm
controlling the whole battlefield like
just freezing and stopping and throwing
well you have a stasis turn right you
have a stasis man you can shut down half
the room you could shut down and then
when i told you that travelers chose it
which is now giving me high up time on
grenades high up like you could the
builds you can play with warlock and
stasis i will admit it's
i don't i can't speak for the hunters
but i feel dominant with shade binder
i'm doing i did my first grand master
with shade binder at least i can put up
a wall that gets destroyed in two shots
and our bubble gets destroyed even
quicker now because unless you're
running 10 resilience yeah
yeah that's wrong i don't see a problem
i see i i see storm called shout out to
the storm caller warlocks that's busting
y'all bubbles right now did you see that
tweet just above god i'm like damn
yeah yeah is that one of the first
supers that's been affected by a stat by
the way i was actually i'm kind of
wondering
that's interesting i i think they should
do that more to be honest because then
you could build your uh your classes
like stat build around this yeah they
would just need to redo their system to
make it more like
uh like clear what because i wouldn't
know like how easy is it to break my
bubble based on my resilience and that
sort of stuff but yeah uh tight titans
are getting the squeeze right now i i
think some of that will change with the
i agree you guys gotta get a bottom
right yeah
don't complain we're not hunters
what about you teddy what are your
thoughts on this whole thing anything
sound cool or just is there anything
that you can picture as a combination of
stuff that you're like i want to put
these two trees together is there
anything you're just like waiting to
play with
yeah the uh the ability
trade-off between the riffs or the
lifesteal
i think that's that's really smart
because because you're getting the
opposite it allows you to yes
uh get this like really high up time
which is what the update was what they
say and you kind of already do that with
devourer like that's already kind of how
you need to play that subclass to get
the use out of it
um
but it's the same thing i said earlier
like i think this system is just
it's
it's what
we asked for the d1 system and they gave
us something better yeah and and that's
and that's what we preach right like
like like you you're
the ability to have the choices
that you have are just
and it shows now more than ever i think
now that we have all the aspects and
fragments for stasis
like you said shade binder in pve is
just nuts
just the turret alone alone
is nuts and then you have your your
melee you have your the super's really
good um like that's the de facto
warlock super for most gm's you're not
even running well anymore because what
you just die in your well anyway and
it's like well yeah might as well at
least have something offensive that i
can
um
give them a taste of medicine and give
boss decent boss dps
right it's the versatile super go on
yeah no but that's it i mean like
we've gone through all the changes and i
think it's just
i'm excited like i just want to see them
i mean titans are getting a little
shafted but i i think they'll i think
they'll
come around at least we're going to get
bubble for which queen rays which means
titans are going to be
uh a little more valuable
we're not worried about it
striker is pretty good in crucible right
now yeah
bigger springs and hammers top tree
hammers mm-hmm that's i've been using
actually top tree hammers yeah i was
like the tracking slash explosion has
definitely got me a couple collaterals
plenty of times on so i always enjoy
hammers but it's why i try not to live
on them
if i'm gonna lock down a point though
for something like iron banner if i go
bottom tree hammers and just sit there
in my in my fire dude i throw so many
and then if i go phoenix uh cradle i can
just like coat the entire room in this
inferno of fire and i'm just like come
on in
anybody want in no cool
[Laughter]
come play so before we jump into just
like one last little thing uh just kind
of seeing where you guys are at for this
week for like a little matchmaking
discussion if you guys even want to get
into that i wanted to see
you've had a kind of a we talk about
matchmaking enough yeah no
no it was more like iron banner in the
skill base just have you guys noticed a
lot of people are posting things on
twitter with regards to
matchmaking
like lobbies being kind of wonky like
all over have you guys seen what i'm
talking about do you know have you felt
it either and that's the other question
i would say like 90 of my matches i
have
uh
have ended the match in a mercy and the
other 10 i've been mercy
like it's been like a way 100
mercy rate in my iron banner matches
that's been my experience but again i'm
like playing with friends or that's not
true though i did some freelance and it
was kind of the same thing so i don't
know
well i iron banner's kind of been like
that for a couple seasons now yeah
normal pvp i was also experiencing that
last week and that's usually not the
case
they did clarify that the spm is they
didn't change anything but i think the
team balancing is actually what's like
yep
messed up
um
the the working theory on like how team
balancing works in destiny is it it
gives players um that numbers arbitrary
but like just for the sake of example it
gives players a rank from zero to ten
zero being like absolutely terrible and
the ten being like god tier and then the
way that it's balancing is like say like
travis is an eight or nine it'll put
travis you know he's like the top player
on that team and then it's gonna give
him a bunch of twos and threes yeah but
then the other team is a bunch of fours
fives and sixes so you're averaging the
same but
you only have one player and one team
who's like actually knows what he's
doing and the other the other five
aren't and so i think that effect has
been exacerbated for one reason or
another some people were suggesting like
oh more people are on pve right now
um because it's the beginning of the
season but i think they did did they say
they switched it to a snake draft
i was wondering about i was wondering
the same thing i was like yeah i wasn't
sure about the snake was like kind of
just like back and forth potentially
doing a snake draft which is maybe not
much better than what they were doing
with averages but i i thought that they
were using iron banner as their guinea
pig for that
um i remember them talking about how the
iron banner playlist was going to be
different but whatever they're doing i
think the data will probably show it's
not working because there's just there's
been anecdotally speaking obviously i'm
not i'm not like a
data scientist with access to all the
information but it just anecdotally on
my end like it has not been a balanced
experience at all right i mean i iron
banner in general the last year like i
i'm always rolling with a six stack and
we're always immersing like it's pretty
rare yeah but your group is the
sweatiest of the sweat lords like i know
who you play with i mean they're they're
even they make me look casual
i'm serious dude he plays with like i
believe like 5.0 okay guys
yeah it's ridiculous
dude are you like one of your guys like
literally has a 5.0 i've seen it it's
ridiculous maybe maybe this season in in
the playlist but not like overall they
don't they're all like 2.0 3.0 people
yes
far beyond me you get you you get
carried and you're not a bad player
yourself you're getting carried by those
guys but yeah i mean it's
it's
anyway iron band has just been like that
regardless like yeah whether you're on
the receiving end or the one dishing it
out so
something
has to change but overall
i mean i'm sure in like two weeks it's
gonna go back to the way it was at the
end of last season
yeah it's probably just some some player
shifting
you know
priorities and where players are and
what not yeah like mixed bag for me you
guys said pretty much same points you
know just varied results um i you know i
just think it's fun when i see the the
playstation logo in there and i'm like
ah okay would it be a cross play thing
do you think maybe that's something that
balances that's why i was thinking we'll
say dude i matched up against some
stadia people and like i just felt bad
for them because it was oh you saw it
one in in there two two stadia guys
you found both of them good job you
found two in the wild
yeah
and also teddy and i were noticing like
every every time we matched against the
playstation group when we were playing
it was just a a slaughter like just a
yeah the x-men
popping off right now
so something to note though if is if
you're you can only play pc people if
you have a pc if you have a pc person so
so us playing on pc last night we were
only getting console people because they
had a pc person
gotcha but but if you're playing on
console you you got the whole besides pc
you have the entire pool
so
uh i think maybe that might be
it could be yeah what's what's affecting
it more than the pc cycle i mean i don't
know for me the pc stuff
it's larger than the same like right
yeah because you're not noticing it but
i am when i play with you i'm like all
right these are pc players yeah yeah
they're worse yeah but what you do any
experience on that uh i've had a lot of
mercies both directions a lot of mercies
both directions i had that one that i
sent you guys for a joke for
my one match that was like one that was
pretty like 125 to 110 and i actually
like kind of went off with like 40.
so i was like i had a decent game but
like outside of that one and the one
that was literally 125 to 124 there were
like two decent ones
almost every other one was mercy so
there's definitely
it doesn't seem like it doesn't have to
be sweaty all the time but the scales
are tipping pretty hard a lot of the
time it seems so again i don't know yeah
if it's anything too specific that like
anybody can track down right now but it
definitely does seem
i don't know even the best way to say it
just off for whatever reason it just
seems like not as many mercies
happened previously and this does seem
like a lot iron banner's always going to
be a bit skewed and weird but still i
got mercy'd with a 3.0 oh wow
wow
i was just like wow that was a really
short match and i was like did we mercy
them and then i was like oh i got mercy
that's funny
you're like it's always the funny way
like yo i'll be like well i did my thing
what the hell was going on here
yeah you're like oh i got like i got
like five kills cool it's like i had
half of my team's kills oh crap
yeah we've got also a lot of i think
part of the mercying might be the fact
that nobody's playing the objective
right now because they're just trying to
completely yes yes that's
the other problem
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah and this one what is it pulses and
then
um sidearms
i'm just going to get sidearm kills and
i'm not going to worry about capturing i
see people literally stand right next to
the zone and they got their sidearm out
and they just shoot and i'm just like
all right let's see what's going on here
but um yeah the startup's decent i like
it it's decent i don't know how i feel
about the pulse yet i'm like what is
that 390. cool guy actually has a very
interesting video about that i watched
it he he dunked on it he's like that
reticle's trash yeah yeah the red
movement
yeah it's not bad
like true vanguard was talking about
that slider i'm like he's a big siren
guy i've always noticed him kind of
mention those he he was kind of raving
about the sidearm i saw somewhere so
he's that's definitely enjoying that one
that's my favorite sidearm archetype
actually because i
my the one that i'm dominant with is um
the season the beyond light one the red
white and blue what is it a high albedo
or something yeah i think it's that 491
archetype is really dominant in my
opinion in pv i i have tremendous
success with it so i think it's it's
that and it also comes stasis stuff
perks with that one i think right with
that it does okay yeah that's gonna get
headstone on it yeah teddy i'm sorry try
it all right
the sidearms are kind of in the last
like year year and a half they've been
doing a really good job about like
updating slowly updating every arc type
of weapon
and kind of changing stuff in meaningful
ways like they're doing much more
fine tuning of stuff and they've got a
lot better balancing game's not
obviously perfect but uh sidearms are
kind of last uh hold out like it's the
last gun type that really hasn't seen
any changes in a long time
um like the fusion rifles and scouts
were sort of the other you know they're
in the same yeah but they just did those
this season so yeah um it's just
sidearms now so i i hope with which
queen maybe we finally get a sidearm
pass and maybe they'll actually become
useful because i like them in d1 like
trespasser and the iron banner and d1
were super fun to use yeah especially
when special ammo was uh when they were
cool that was the count because you
always had that side off up time yep
right so um
yeah i just hope they i hope they bring
it back i do like the new one because
it's the three burst one which reminds
me of uh what was it last hope and i
thought yeah last stance i think
are the other two
give us a sidearm power weapon
actually did you guys there's one more
thing did you guys notice
he's um his face was amazing yeah
he's like i'm like
it's easy
it's easy it's homing bullets there you
go so it's not ironic it's like is it
like is it like a desert eagle type
sidearm
it's the it's the pistol from halo combo
you're funny yeah that's actually it
there you go there you go
what does it do somehow these bullets
will kill you like across the map with
like with one bullet inside it's got a
sniper scope on it yeah teddy what did
you say about the iron banner so the new
iron banner weapons uh when you triple
cap they glow uh like they have like
fire on them they glow fire your red
really uh i hadn't actually noticed that
i got a fantastic notice
i noticed that last night we were
playing because i was doing my sidearm
kills and
the first time it happened i was kind of
like oh that's weird my gun's on fire
that's kind of odd and then it happened
again i'm like oh it's because we're
triple capping that's kind of ah that's
dope i didn't know that yeah shout out
to the uh yeah the watch i don't know if
it does it with last season's the
shotgun and the machine gun but
probably would it's the same model
yeah it does it with these two
so yeah shout out to the weapon design
it'd be good i don't know about that
armor though i do not know about that
armor at all that arm is
don't mind the general glance at it
though
that rolls on it though i'm gonna just
i'm gonna transmog that set because i
was getting like 65s all day
um there's a new like armor set thing
that they kind of introduced with this
iron banner gear where the more pieces
you wear up to four pieces you have a
higher chance of getting an enhancement
prism yep
oh that's right for end game players for
us you know that's
not really an issue because i'm just
rolling in prisons but i can see it for
a more like
kind of get on every night type of
person um
like that's a great way to get hands on
prisms you're just just not like you're
just playing the game and you're in
there
i don't know what the drop rate is and
i'm assuming you have to wear all four
pieces but yeah um
yeah like where's the indicator teddy on
like
so when you inspect the armor it's odd
yeah it's on it's it's at the bottom
like where okay an exotic perk would
normally be for a weapon oh
for this set it's only if you play iron
banner with and you're wearing iron
banner that's where that armor gives you
so the flavor text says and then you
have to have a certain amount of pieces
to have it if the more it goes
yeah the more you have the higher the
chance up to the higher the chance yeah
okay
minimum a minimum one a maximum of four
because you also have an exotic on got
it yeah exactly okay and yes
i've i've been wanting them to do armor
sets forever like when they did when
they did the uh the gambit stuff
um
like yeah i mean it was busted and it
totally didn't work but like and they
did it for revelry too
it was a cool thing but like
they just have never done it again and i
mean this this isn't like amazing but
it's just cool to have it right like
something well that's about as good of a
segue as i can possibly ask for but i'm
just gonna jump
my own question
because of what i was trying to wait and
you guys just kept going on iron banner
sorry sorry oh no no you were good i was
just waiting for an opening but i didn't
quite get one
i was thinking of what you guys from
witch queen if there's anything else you
thought about from witch queen or if
there's anything else you
didn't see that you wanted to
and mine
was armor 3.0 any kind
because
that's not it i'm gonna be straight up
that's not it
because even with stasis as it is right
now
all that is is just match another color
so you can use different mods
and they've mentioned still okay fine
i'll take
five pieces of armor that i get this
season
turn them all to stasis
and
master work them and then i really don't
need then i have four sets of armor to
keep not three but that's literally the
only difference and then i never need
armor again because all that stuff's
gone
so my biggest thing that i'm and again i
know they didn't show everything with
regards to witch queen but the biggest
thing that i want to see is have armor's
got to work differently for me armor
crafting by lightfall i
maybe yeah that'd be beautiful but
like i
if all we're doing is just
getting the same like if you get a good
stat roll for your build there is no
reason to go after like more than half
of your gear
without you know like the set bonus for
iron banner is kind of cool
is that going to be are we going to get
set bonuses is there going to be
anything but that was a double down on
set bonuses because i they're
they don't have like randomly rolled
perks like weapons do on armor and i
think if they implemented something like
that people would be pissed because
people love to change their armor perks
out all the time and that sort of stuff
or their their mods so i think they have
to just do set bonuses right like what
is your suggestion for you that's gonna
ask you like what would satisfy you well
even if it's like exciting some
mentioned stuff that i've mentioned
before like hey higher end activities or
if you go to the legendary campaign you
can earn some of the witch queen
campaign armor that has
more energy to it just i want some
tweaks to the armor if they can't go big
like
you know like stats on the armor only do
so much you could literally as if it's
got an okay roll your end game's not
really going to completely change if you
have like a 20 here or a 10 here or 5
here you can probably get through most
content even with ok stats the stats
don't feel like they have much weight to
them in the first place like mobility
doesn't make you run faster that still
blows my mind
resilience is only useful for a titan
and you guys would much rather just not
have it on there most of the time
um and then the others just like
recharge times and it's
i know that dives deeper into the rpg
and they haven't mentioned it again
we're talking about like how much
bandwidth do they have and covet and
stuff like that but
for
i don't know
maybe you can earn more energy so you
can use more freedom with mods since
they just jacked up the scavenger mods
anyway i just should armor have perks in
addition to mods i would be okay with
even if it's just like one
i don't know just some way to give me
more of a reason to go after armor
because if i take a stasis set and i
master work all of those i can literally
basically just like delete the rest of
my titan armor outside of exotics and
never need one again for legendary
either because i've got
it may not be the pr and then it's like
oh i got a slightly better stat rule
okay i switched that one out and then my
currencies are still going to be
chilling so for me it's just hope of
something because they even mentioned it
i guess that's why i still have hope
and because at some point joe groth said
especially now with transmog being a
thing that you're not even looking at it
at some point we're gonna make sure that
you're not just replacing your stats
every year yeah and now we're not even
replacing stats every year because sun
setting's gone because so they wanted to
do that before sunsetting and now that
sunset is here there's even more of a
reason because what you have is never
leaving right and that's why i know you
go off at sunset because i think sunset
go counteracts exactly
what you're looking for and it could be
preventative to that but yeah travis
you're going to say something's uh
before going i was just going to ask you
guys because i don't really know this
um
what what is the point of ascendant
shards if you never have to masterwork
any armor after your first like three
sets or whatever
good question why do you question why
grand masters over and over and over
yeah it seems like a currency that the
endgame community really cares about and
i don't because yeah because you don't
do it
what it is too is like
because armor now as i talked about the
stasis armor there are very high quality
perks
that are locked behind
energy armor sets so so that's one time
right you get one set and you make that
your stasis set right so but for yes for
each for each one you know they i guess
people just say you know they they
really want to go with the i don't even
call it min maxing but it's just they
really want those high-end you know
perks on the void or the solar or
whatever whatever and that they're ex
there's so many perks that are exclusive
per thing and i guess that's they just
wouldn't have those three to four of
them and they're their lives
so far i've got like i've got a
masterwork set for my titan a solar and
can avoid fully masterworked
so at this point
you know how many does it take to ascend
one piece of armor one shard
one okay and then prisms yeah exotics
are three
three yeah yeah so if you want to like
have a vault full of like masterworked
exotic armor and everyone's a good role
that's about the only place you would
put it and that is such a short list of
people
who probably would be teddy is for sure
there's a couple of you but i've always
i've always not had a lot of a senate
shards and uh ascendant prisms and all
that stuff and i've never needed them so
i'm always confused when people are like
oh it's double golf ball weekend
i'm like what are you doing
what are you actually doing with these
golf balls because it's it's the it's
now either mid-mass game which is like i
for warlock i want hot like i got like a
hundred intellect a hundred recovery
you know up like up time up time is is
just so key for me you know for again
just talk about the warlock play style
so that that's what it is you know those
those three key stats and what it is is
when you when you master work with teddy
don't you get the plus 10 or less
on each different thing so now you get
to push into certain thresholds where
you get these really spiky
builds on certain stats that it's it's a
minutiae you know
yeah
it's um
sorry to cut you off it's basically just
like it's just min maxing like it's been
back
for for me it's if i can get on and
grind and i fall you know five or six
times in a night and i can get point
five percent better
i'm cool with that the problem that i
have and you kind of you guys kind of
alluded to this is all my armor is 64 or
higher yeah i have so many different
variations of different spikes that i
like so in order for me to replace an
armor piece now the sun setting is not a
thing it has to be 65 or higher yep
or the distribution has to be in such a
way that it lines up with the one of the
sets that i have that i want to swap
something out and it'll make that a
little bit better but
the problem is that the only place this
really ever matters is in a grand master
and yes you don't you don't feel this
in your moment-to-moment gameplay
because you know having that extra
two seconds shaved off my grenade or
whatever like it's just it's all passive
stuff in the back yeah and i think
that's that's the problem the other
issue that uh we haven't brought up is
the mods are now very oversaturated yeah
i introduced armor 2.0 we didn't have
them any mods but now you're especially
that final slot you're competing for so
many different yeah so you want to
create and then for pve protective light
you always have to have all of your own
content and that and that takes a
minimum of two so uh two slots because
you charge light plus plus uh protected
protected light
and so then you're only left with three
slots that you can use
yeah for void wells war mine cells um
i mean there's so much that uh
that there is there so i i want them to
rework it i don't think it's gonna come
with witch queen yeah yeah i mean that
like can you imagine if there were just
like three or four
slots and you could pick anything to go
in those
i mean i do think
just like i want them to change it up to
a point where as you said like you're
you're beyond most of us even the three
of us because you've farmed way beyond
the rest of us if you're like i'm 64s i
got everything covered you probably have
a set of everything your stasis set if
it's not done it'll be done this season
so when you go into which queen
why do you even why do you need armor
besides looks
well that's right that's what i was
going to get at is in the in the words
of orson krennic farming really a man of
your talent
good reference
it's a peaceful life
so
uh with every expansion
or or new release in destiny choose case
they've invalidated our progress in some
way
uh whether it was both weapons and armor
or just weapons and armor yep they
haven't said anything for witch queen
explicitly but i do think
that they will like there's going to be
a new version of either armor or weapon
that they're going to introduce that
it's not going to you're not going to
completely like throw out the old stuff
right it's gonna slowly replace it um
because you're gonna want that new stuff
and i my hope is that it's armor instead
of weapons but i i think it will be
weapons because of the crafting stuff
the way they're talking about crafting
makes it seem like
um that you're gonna have options like
you're gonna you're gonna work on one
weapon for a long time and then you'll
you don't because he made a reference to
like oh you don't need three glaives in
your vault you're just gonna have the
one glaive and you go you go to the
crafting table and then you can like
upgrade it and change stuff on it over
time and so i that's why i think it's
going to be weapons over armor but i
want them to change the armor system
in a more impactful way
um
because i have no reason like like like
i said the armor has to be 65 or higher
for me to agree i agree um and that's
you know that's already asking a lot
like it's it's extremely rare that armor
piece drops 65 or higher for me yeah
that just doesn't happen
yeah i i think you know that's
the source of ease frustration and i
feel them because it's like where where
is he's he's getting into the sunken
place like how we were with trials like
he's in he's in that dark zone like they
don't care about me and i i love it
there's a part of me that loves it
because now he knows how i feel with
trials took forever me and travis was
suffering so hard for them to even talk
about it and it just seems that they're
not talking but i do think
it will happen
my concern is if
because i know how much you want it my
concern for you is how robust is it
actually going to be and is that going
to be satisfactory for you and if in
order for it to be satisfactory i think
it probably needs to be kind of like
what teddy said one or two things where
this new 3.0
eventually is going to clean out
the old right
or
what you may you know the the sun
setting with the armor and stuff like
that so they've got to figure it out i
don't like that like some signal of
armor was just going to be something
they have weapons
in general right right well some setting
of weapons is going to help them with
things like they'd love to probably
slowly phase out like rampage and kill
clip if they're trying to get these more
unique perks to be as travis said a
little bit more viable right you don't
see those nearly as often
but with armor it was going to be more
annoying because you're like i have a
good role what's going to happen when a
sunset i want the same thing
that's the thing they've got to get rid
of so however they and again if they do
like with forsaken random roles kind of
phased out the early stuff then we've
got you know that type of
as teddy said that's the type of thing
you need a reason to get the new stuff
you might be good with your set for a
while but at some point you're like all
right there's things over here the
functionality i need on the new stuff is
something that i'm going to want going
forward you can work on slowly mixing
that in but it needs to have something
big enough that somebody like teddy
who's good to go right is willing to
literally go after new sets for a reason
right that's
it's got to be kind of big and that's
why again they haven't mentioned
anything they have six months but that's
my one i didn't mean to steal this
entire piece of the conversation by the
way but like that's my one thing
that's my one thing like which queen is
amazing amazing amazing but if they
don't do anything with armor it's still
like
five eight five eights of my gear that's
like
okay
i i have a prediction i i think
this is a bunch they're not they're not
stupid they they they recognize i think
the issue comes down to
the way the road map is structured and i
think the what your what your want is
contingent on is the classes and stuff
getting done first so i think that's
what's happening so you're you're on
like we're in the room you're on the
board but until void solar consolidation
then they really could do what they want
to do and i think i think you're gonna
get it it's just gonna be
sadly i know i was hoping too by which
queen it'd be it'd be here and i i
thought we would be here but let's be
real trial set them back crazy we were
coming at their throats you know what
i'm saying we're just now getting that
now the the the the the consolidation of
sub classes and stuff like that cross
play that's all it is i just think you
just got bumped down but i think you
will get it it's just it's going to
probably
i don't want to say final shape it's
going to be it's
the armor is going to go right into that
right it's going to affect like the
perks and that stuff if they if they
redo it i agree they have to do the
classes i agree the classes are frankly
more important like that the the armor's
not you breaking his heart you break it
he's hot it's just careful it's just
it's just not interesting it doesn't
make you make interesting decisions but
it's not like it's actively broken like
some of the subclasses are just filled
with imbalances and stuff that those
need to go first yeah and then remember
the rumored additional class too right
the
whether it be poison or whatever
which is not is not coming until late
fall they've confirmed that so but wait
at least they've even acknowledged it
right yeah they actually said it's not
coming this time they fly right the
first thing it exists
in which queen they're not going to drop
that in a season could be before
i doubt they would drop a subclass
without an expansion destiny it's a new
life we don't know what this new body
the only reason i'm going to say that is
because we've specifically talked about
the marketing machine and if you're
going to sell an expansion you put a
subclass in it
also yeah the fact that they're
splitting up each um
light subclass into a season they're
going to use that as marketing for sure
oh yeah yeah i thought you sell that's
how you sell it yeah that's exactly
right so it's like oh solar subclass is
getting revealed
this stuff so every season before the
expansion they kind of do this thing
where they fatten us up and they're like
yep all right here here's the season of
the loot it's really easy to get the
loot and then the expansion comes and
it's like yeah all that stuff you did it
kind of doesn't matter
put that in the trash and they they've
been doing it they figured that formula
out with opulence yes and then they just
and they uh
and they've been doing it ever since
completely agree teddy that is the
playbook
well i apparently made my own topic with
armor 3.0 hopes but is there anything
else you guys with regards to which
queen that you wanted to mention before
we wrap it up since we're at a close to
three hour stream
what's missing from which cream aside
from armor 3.0 i mean just is there
anything else with regards to which
queen that like you know you thought was
really cool that we hadn't talked about
previously or just you know as i said
kind of a hope that's not in there yet
are we talking about leaks because there
was a leak this week
oh there's a new one there was a new one
yeah teddy we talked about it can we
tell it's kind of a retailed one but it
got confirmed
can we tell our fans to invert their
ears oh yeah
his eyes went real wide
is this about to be a big giant spoiler
warning wave your hand situation we got
we got a spo so there's been a there was
a leak a long time okay hold on you know
giants
i'm not going to go into
there was a paste bin from a long time
ago and then this week there was new
stuff that surfaced that confirmed one
of the major pieces of that more or less
confirmed it it's like a 90 certainty as
far as i'm concerned and that is what
teddy and i have been talking about so
that that's sort of a big witch queen
like it's probably going to be we might
cover that one off air just yeah so we
don't have like spoilers in the episode
i won't i won't spoil it but basically
there's something in the witch screen
trailer you have to really pay attention
like yeah like you need to be free
like technically not a leak it is a
trailer adobe premiere like frame by
frame situation this is what i'm framed
by frame joints you got you got to
really look at this and then pause it
and
it's super tiny and you got to recognize
it and then you'll know what it is but
it essentially confirmed
a large chunk of the of the paceman
um or a major point i just say not a
large chunk i mean most most of the
basement at this point is has been true
there's only a couple days but some of
it has been wrong as as
i pointed out last week
cool well apparently if you want to go
look up that thing um
go look it up see if you figure out what
they're talking about go do it your damn
style yeah i don't i don't want to do it
on here we've had a good fun clean
episode i don't know like a big spoiler
god do red bad i love it
we hear them rumors do that we shoot
that damn like yo his punk is garbage
shout out to dude i love him
um i also i also hate uh leaks it's the
worst thing i ever did
but yeah that's gonna be episode number
164. it's about a six hour episode
by the point two yeah
164.2 part two whatever you guys want to
call it the encore
post intermission
yes
thank you for attending
this live production of the last word
episode 164. part one and two can be
listed combined
if you like
just a six hour upload on youtube
people just lose their minds
yeah do a separate upload man on on a
bridge on a bridge right the unabridged
yeah with 15 minutes of uh intermission
music in between
[Music]
that's my proposal for that video
don't i don't know if the six hour video
is gonna do too hot in the algorithm but
you know we'll maybe maybe later
uh but man teddy like man couldn't have
had you for more of a stellar seriously
double encore marathon episode
i don't know i don't know if this one
buys you like 40 episodes or we'll get
back on the 21 i don't know how much
time this buys you but we'll definitely
get you back in when it's uh needed but
uh if you got anything you got cooking
up anything that where people can find
you what you're doing or just like hey i
have a really fun hobby if you want to
talk to me about it you know i'm your
guy like what do you got going cooking
or otherwise sir
yeah so uh
first of all thank you for having me
again uh it's always a pleasure to sit
down with the family and you already
know and get the talk going we had some
heated discussions
yeah
but uh you can you can follow me on
twitter at teasingteddy i'm sure it's in
the video um it's all one word i'm
usually just posting memes or trolling
someone i work with uh i don't take
twitter seriously at all so
if you try to take me seriously i will
troll you back
my pinned tweet is a picture of friend
milo bella's signed copy of mario kart
double dash so if that doesn't give you
an indication of like what kind of memes
i like in my life
but uh lately i've been uh i've been
working a lot of console modding and
different things like that so if you're
into that stuff sometimes i do post some
of the crazy stupid things that travis
has told me that i'm wasting my time
doing um like last night i spent about
four hours attempting to figure out
how to circumvent dhcp for my ps3 so i
can capture my ps3 so i failed
so
it was it was a complete waste of time
and i wish i could have taken it back
but uh yeah i think tonight i might also
might dive into some other consoles
because i got this whole set up for work
and
and whatnot but uh that's what i got
going on so thanks again this is always
fun i'm always happy to talk destiny and
you already know rage a little inside
this is like it's like therapy you know
it's therapy yeah it's like therapeutic
for us yeah we get it out we get it out
it helps me get online
therapy session
please lay down on the couch
please lay down on the couch and tell me
how has destiny pained you this week
point to where destiny touched me
[Laughter]
i was trying to be reasonable
yep completely killed it totaled traffic
dhcp
yes yes
travis took a left as he does
[Laughter]
touch
did he touch
[Laughter]
okay
you can also find me on twitter unlike
teddy i take twitter extremely seriously
all my posts uh are just
pieces of art
i don't have a pinned post i don't know
how to do that
and you can also
you can read my uh previews reviews and
articles on ign.com uh today or maybe
tomorrow i have a preview no
oh wait yeah that's not going live until
next week okay i can talk about it but i
it's not uh the embargo is next week i
did a preview of um world war z
aftermath which is the new expansion
coming out for uh that zombie apocalypse
game which is pretty cool so you can
read that and watch the video next week
um
and then uh yeah other than that i'm you
know i'll be here on this show and then
i also do a show on sunday mornings
called bitcast where i talk about games
that aren't destiny except last week i
spent like 35 minutes talking about
destinations
everyone hated me great it was awesome
awesome i love it it was beautiful i
mean in the greens i also warned all the
viewers to not play destiny if they're
not playing it currently they were like
how how would you recommend people get
in and i was like don't like just if
you're not already in like don't do it
like please don't let's go
use me as an example so this is what you
can become
what are you what are you in a
cautionary tale yeah
the addiction is real we have to take
him to his destiny anonymous every week
i've told you a picture of teddy after a
marathon of destiny and i said do you
want to look like this
you did that look at his twitter you did
no i didn't i should have though it
would have been probably more impactful
i've told travis this before many times
but i'll say this publicly a lot of
times when i boot destiny up i try to
figure out how i can do things as fast
as possible so i don't have to play
destiny as much as i should be playing
or can't be
and actually it's gotten to the point
where i question whether he likes
destiny at all
i i do wanna once like a drug addiction
he can't quit
he was looking up videos for how to do
stuff in the ascendant plane the
shattered plane or whatever and i was
like dude this is like the one fun thing
that destiny added that is like fun to
discover on your own and you're
literally figuring out how to just like
bypass all the puzzles and exploration
to get out as quickly as possible like
what is wrong with you like i'm actually
really enjoying it just not using any uh
any uh guides for that but it's good
good to know my youtube videos did not
come from yeah
don't worry yeah for three hours every
week i don't need to listen to him
anymore in the middle of the week three
hours is all he gets
teddy was using your video though i know
he wouldn't go to anyone else for
content oh yeah yeah
click on it
the first one that
[Applause]
oh yeah no i i literally i was waiting
for him to pull up the video or in party
chat and i didn't hear bontes voice and
i was like
you can also um you can find uh the best
tutorials to destiny on ubuntu's youtube
channel yes yes um so go there
also you'll find lots of ads for
advanced.gigi which i hear is a powder
you can turn into a liquid and then
drink it out of a cup so
if you like to put uh
wet things down your mouth hole i highly
recommend
there's a lot of jokes there buddy
there's a lot of jokes there wow
wow he did it
to the audience for everything you heard
in the last 60 seconds please disregard
that from the can i have that
a disclaimer we here at the last week
do not condone the words of travis
mcclunkey north of but we thank you for
your time
oh my salute to the fam it was another
great one passionate a lot of stuff
going on breaking down the mechanics of
everything teddy's the home he's always
good you know it's just an extension
this is like party chats this is this is
what we do so salute to everybody yeah
man you already know me lordcognito on
twitter and all that good stuff uh catch
me on last stand media thanks for the
defining duke support really means a lot
i've been seeing a lot of control with
the little hashtags and the tweets and
stuff like that matt he's an absolute
beast my man but he he ain't no e but he
you know he's he's he's working he's up
there working man maddie is definitely
that's the whole thing he's
i'm just amazed as an older person like
damn like i feel like an antiquated
podcasting model i'm like you guys are
the new
you know saying like if this they're
this young doing this this well like
what the hell for obsolete but i salute
and of course i lost podcast no iop this
sunday because obviously i will be going
away being solved will be there as well
but uh we will still give you all
something we have kind of a personal
kind of like round table where the uh we
had the fans and the patreons uh ask us
real questions about other things
besides games so that will be debuting
in the spot this sunday 1 p.m check that
out it will be fun and then of course
the last word
e travis the thai guy the cheetah back
in the building man it's always fun this
is a lot of stuff going on destiny is a
fun time it is always good to talk to
the homie so eat what is going on with
you sir by the way i retweet your videos
and i watched them just for the record
unlike these heathens uh some of these i
watched them twice just to pump up those
numbers
you're just sitting there you got like
two computers one's just playing in the
background thanks for the the background
views appreciate the love
no honestly like it's been busy for me
for like guides and things uh gonna work
on a leveling guide for because honestly
that type of stuff people will fall into
this season because it's so long all
season so it's definitely gonna be
uh it's gonna be a season of like trying
to cover lots of different things um
yeah
and then just obviously seeing what
happens around december but i mean right
now it's just there's weekly guides over
where the ascendant anchors are where
the skus are where everything is in the
shattered realm
and then you know couple things in there
which lost sector pops up is an easy one
to farm it's always something to usually
do on for a little while at some point
it'll run out but for now on a random
note i did figure out who at some point
i've got to kind of reach out
i figured out who has the word cheetah
as their
twitter handle
ah we doing it
oh no i it's i'm not taking it i just
gotta shout the guy out at some it's
tyree kill for the chiefs
because he is
oh yeah he's literally he's literally
like the fastest guy in the nfl
i saw him because my wife's a cheese fan
and somehow like fell through my twitter
feed i was like wait at cheat i'm like
damn
so i was like all right um but yeah
other than that you know consuming that
advanced stuff don't just kidding
[Laughter]
indeed yeah uh but yep for me you guys
might see the lights
my electricity it's uh i'm having
trouble
[Laughter]
no but thank you guys all very much of
course teddy pleasure to have you for
the bonus
um always have fun i like your grounded
approach but there's there's like a d
there's like a strong opinion behind
your very level tone yes yeah
you're like i have strong opinions but i
have to deliver it in a very soothing
asmr tone it fits quite well and always
appreciate that uh but travis of course
is like the opposite of you yeah you see
screeching into the mind you guys
balance each other out and then cog and
i of course always bounce off of each
other so we're like the light in the
dark
yeah
and the line between us is so very thin
the line is very thin
it's about six pixels maybe maybe maybe
seven i'm not sure
uh somebody has a construction truck
backing up right now
okay i was like
oh i thought i was gonna call [ __ ] out
and i was like no he's ready to get me
i'm like nope nope he's got that sure
mic sorry guys i think they're saying
back this podcast
probably back back it up to the end so
we'll write at three hours guys for the
recording thank you chap so much very
much thanks for supporting the switch
over to youtube we will keep this thing
going for many reasons it seems to work
pretty well so thank you guys all for
hanging out here on the channel uh for
episode number 164.2
um teddy travis and cog thank you
gentlemen very much for hanging tonight
for everybody in chat thank you all and
for this episode it has been
the last word